yeah guys we're here for day three of
the NFL Draft can't wait obviously a lot
of teams with a lot of picks left today
it's gonna be me and Matt no left go the
guy deserves a breather the guy's been
doing a ton it's been absolutely crazy
so me and Matt are gonna have you
covered for at least rounds four and
five we're gonna talk about a lot of
different teams how they've done certain
teams have more picks another I know the
Vikings I think are sitting there with
at least 13 picks it's gonna be
absolutely nuts so as we look a lot of
good players left on the board as well
we haven't seen all the quarterbacks go
yeah I think we expected somebody like
Jake from somebody like Jacob Eason we
thought they were around 2 or round 3
projected picks so it's gonna be very
very interesting as you look at the top
players available but let's talk about
that talent not just the quarterbacks
ameet Robertson to me yes he's a smaller
corner a guy that projects in the slot
at the next level but I think he plays
at a very very high level I do think he
could survive on the outside because of
how physical he is and then you look at
in the pass rush group I'm very
surprised that a guy like Bradley and I
has not come off the board yet when
we've seen a lot of other names in the
edge group come off the board first
whether it's a guy like Daryl Taylor
Giuliano Cora Jabari Zuniga Jonathan
greener those guys went first before a
night but double-digit sacks this year
for Utah Bryce Hall is a very
interesting case I think Bryce Hall
really could have been a top 50 top 40
pick obviously the fractured ankle has
teams concerned and you look at the
value of a player like that if he can
get healthy he can get right so it's
gonna be a really fun day with a lot of
talent on the board the skilled group
still has plenty of players I think a
lot of people are wondering where is
somebody like Donovan people's Jones
gonna go in this class and Matt it's
great to have you here with me welcome
back buddy let's make this a really good
day yeah let's make it a good day our
tech issues starting a little bit early
today hopefully that's the only one we
get today's show is sponsored by rocket
mortgage rocket mortgage in people
across the country are joining together
to say thank you to all the essential
workers
who leave their home so we can say stay
so we can stay safe in our homes share
your thanks for the folks on the front
lines by posting your thank you video to
everyone knows a hero dot-com
Connor it is gonna be fun today it's
gonna go fast it's going to furious
we're gonna do our best to acknowledge
the comments leave those in the app
right here below our producers are gonna
grab those top comments we're gonna
shout them out when we get a chance to
today you did a little bit of a recap
there Connor a lot of good players still
on the board notably some quarterbacks
Jake from Jacob east and some of the big
players that we still see out there
today we did our winners and losers last
night though and one of the big ones is
the Baltimore Ravens what they continue
to do doesn't it feel like we say this
every year Hyundai three we say here go
man all about those Baltimore Ravens
continue to dominate every year the
Ravens have had a very very good draft
so far your winner the Indianapolis
Colts getting weapons for Philip Rivers
but we are on the clock the Cincinnati
but excuse me the Arizona Cardinals at
pick 108 this is any Bengals are gonna
be 107 sorry get caught up a little bit
here so pick 107 Connor gonna be the
Cincinnati Bengals they have added Joe
borough they've added Logan Wilson T
Higgins from Clemson's they've added
athletic playmakers we have a little bit
of time to kind of predict what we think
is gonna happen here for the Bengals
where would you go if you're Duke Tobin
and Cincinnati well Matt I have some
news for us we have the pick for the
Bengals and it looks like they are gonna
go back to the linebacker well again
they took Logan Wilson at the top of the
third round now they're going with app
States Akeem Davis gave ear this is
somebody that reminded me a little bit
of West Virginia's David long junior
from last year yes he's an outside
linebacker but he plays at about 220
pounds so I think this is exciting man
we're gonna talk about this pick to kick
things off yeah I'm very excited for a
team davis Gaither going to Cincinnati
let's do the video
the Cincinnati Bengals went linebacker
and Logan Wilson now they get one of the
most athletic linebackers in a Kim Davis
Gaither from appstate could play inside
Connor Rodgers he could play outside
we love the speed and versatility he
brings to the table what do you think of
this pick in the fit for Cincinnati
going back to the linebacker well
absolutely love this pick would I look
at a team Davis gay there he's one of my
top linebackers on the board here when I
look at he is my top off ball linebacker
available I thought he would have been a
third-round pick Matt the speed the
ability to blitz the ability to stop the
outside run I think he can run and cover
very very well he was the heart and soul
in the middle of this appstate defense
that was quietly a very very good unit
you see the sideline to sideline range
I think this player is gonna come in and
actually have a roll right away as a
nickel backer maybe as a dime backer a
good special teams player very very
different from the player they took in
Logan Wilson in the third round so I
like that the Bengals
I thought they had holes in the middle
of the defense and they said listen
we're gonna wait we're gonna find value
because we think there's talent that's
gonna fall they got two of them this is
an A+ pick for the Bengals that are
knockin this draft out of the park right
now yeah yeah I'm gonna go beat I like
Kim Davis game through I thought the
value was actually really good as well
and you saw the comp there on the lower
thirds Shakima Griffin I think he can be
like you said a nickel linebacker could
play weak side we've seen him get after
the quarterback so the Bengals go back
to the linebacker position this time
they get an athletic specimen who can
play inside or outside backer all right
Connor we promise people who's gonna go
fast and furious today it is going to go
fast and furious that's the beauty of
day 3 where I know a lot of this like
this is where me as a draft fan before I
was a draft analyst this was the moment
you know you'd wake up on Sunday morning
back in the day a day 3 it's where teams
are built you can't overstate that
enough pick 108 overall the Washington
Redskins are on the clock and I have
heard this morning and I've actually
seen our producers say the same thing
now this morning there was a ton of talk
that Trent Williams was going to be
moved today and I think that is what's
going to be a believe very first about
Minnesota we've heard rumors about Tampa
Bay where does Trent Williams
up after we saw some of these teams go
tackle early in the draft so that's
definitely something we're gonna be
monitoring for you today as soon as we
know it we will let you guys know and I
did I say that and I just see a text pop
up on my screen Connor the San Francisco
49ers have traded for Trent Williams my
San Francisco 49ers have traded for
Trent Williams this is a very very big
surprise a 5th this year in a 3rd next
year according to Ian Rapoport of NFL
Network the 49ers have Joe Staley and
Mike McGlinchey so I will tell you I'm a
little confused by this as much as
anyone will be but true Williams two
years ago probably the best left tackle
in football now the Niners add him into
a pretty good line that's already
established and as expected Miller since
this dragged out and the theatrics
continued the return is insanely low a
fifth round pick this year keep in mind
that third next year something tells me
this Niners team is going to be pretty
good I think that'll be one of the final
picks of the third round so I think for
Washington man and it's not Ron Rivera's
fault it's really not it goes back to
Bruce Allen last year not moving him
when they had the chance to get a first
or second-round pick they dragged their
feet it's an awful awful return for
Washington and for the 49ers I'm curious
how the money is gonna look here Miller
I think that's something wolf to die
goes later on in a stick to football
episode when all the details are on the
table
but right now you nailed it they have
two starting tackles is somebody getting
kicked inside I mean at the minimum this
lottery who would be dream Lee
impressive who would it be
it wouldn't be rent there had been talk
to Joe Staley might retire it makes you
wonder if he's decided to do that I'm
speculating completely here but there
was talk I know Niner fans were very
worried even to the point that there was
some consideration for a tackle in round
one I can't believe that that's all
Washington got back for him I was on
with Dan Patrick this week leading up to
the draft and he said you know Miller
they're gonna get a first-round pick for
shirt lamps and I was okay no Dan
Patrick if that's what you say but man
only getting a fifth this year a third
next year the Niners didn't have very
many picks remaining in this trap so
I think that we're gonna see Joe Staley
maybe do a little bit of a draft day
surprise come on say that he is opting
to retire if that's the case you
absolutely love this for the 49ers to
get an even swap if Joe Staley retires
no way you could draft a tackle as good
as what you're getting insurance for
what they got man this is incredible
and I think Trent even at 80% of what he
is we'll see what he comes back to you
but even 80% of Trent Williams is better
than a lot of the tackles in football
that athleticism that strength is a run
blocker in that 49ers scheme it's going
to be absolutely ridiculous yeah it is a
perfect fit so it's gonna be yeah we'll
keep monitoring that definitely a lot of
speculation on Twitter don't forget you
guys can leave your comments in the app
below let us know what you think it's
gonna happen with the San Francisco
49ers we do still have the Washington
Redskins on the clock at pick 108 we're
a little bit ahead of TV right now we're
a little bit ahead of the NFL right now
so waiting to see who goes here Connor
let's look at our top available
Washington got chase young early in this
trap they got antonio gibson an
offensive weapon in around three but
they're still quality players labore we
both have Brice Hall on the board here a
corner from Virginia who would be an
interesting fit for them an injured late
this year a broken ankle that I know
some teams had really flagged him for
medically that's why he could be on the
board here 40 picks later than we had
upgraded yeah I think when you look at
it for Hall he's gonna be one of the
most talented if not the most talented
player taken today and everybody's just
wondering how is he gonna bounce back
because when he was at his best Miller
you're talking about an outside press
corner with insane production on the
ball in 2018 he led the entire entire
college football world in Pass breakup
so I think with Hall it might be a draft
in stache he might need even more time
than we expected but this is the day to
do that you don't do that in rounds two
and three you do it in rounds four five
six and seven so I'm excited to see a
lot of these guys come off the board
very soon yeah and Jacob Eason was
another name up their quarterback from
Washington a player I interviewed on the
six football podcast which people should
check out three times a week in the VR
app or wherever you get your podcast
interviewed him and asked him about hey
there are some questions from scouts
about character and he was straight up
about this thing you know back in
Georgia I had a little bit too much fun
it was a five-star recruit and I
a little too much fun it was 18 years
old I needed a haircut and I needed
someone to kind of kick me in the tail
and get me out of the bars and into
practice but it seems like Connor that
is affecting him today Jacob Eason and
Jake from both still in the board yeah I
think that clearly is and Matt actually
won prop bet I put in this morning I
love your thoughts on it because the
odds were very in favor
I took Jake from to go before Jacob
Eason today and the board the fan duel
here you know in New Jersey does not
think it'll go that way the odds were
heavily in favor of Eason going first
what do you think is gonna happen
between those two yeah I think that is a
very close call Jacob Eason that the
talent is definitely better big arm a
better athlete Jake from but you hear
about all the interviews is great
football IQ we actually have a trade
Connor the Detroit Lions who were on the
clock excuse me no the Redskins have
picked the Lions are on the clock I was
told we had a trade so so skins did try
to lie we're out the world is so focused
on this trade right now nobody is
recording or talking about the picks
everyone is talking about Trent Williams
right now while teams are submitting
their picks and no one is discussing it
exactly yeah so again we'll get caught
up to what's going on apologies for the
the tech issues early this morning so we
have Cincinnati pick was in a Kim Davis
Gaithers linebacker appstate
Washington's on the clock at 108
Detroit's on the clock at 109 there had
been talked that maybe there was a trade
between those teams which the the Lions
would just be moving up one spot so ESPN
had that we did not so we're fixing that
here but again we're on the clock here
for minutes today in between picks so it
is once it gets started it's gonna go
fast it's gonna go furious leave those
comments in the app stay with us for
owns four and five and again let's go
back to Washington we met you chase
young best player in the draft and
Antonio Gibson a player you can play
running back you can play receiver 14
touchdowns at Memphis on 77 touches so
he's an explosive weapon when I looked
at Washington though they need a corner
they need a corner pretty badly we saw
Brice Hall still available Amica
Robertson from Louisiana Tech a little
bit of a smaller player who's incredibly
feisty also still available so if
Washington wants to go corner there are
some good players that would be a fit
here yeah I would go with the meek
Robertson that would make the most sense
to me I think he's somebody that can
play right away he has plenty of play
experience over time once again another
that the ball production was absolutely
ridiculous great hands great return
ability this guy looks to bring it back
to the house after getting the
interception so I looked at him ich
Robertson right here he's being
undervalued clearly because his size
that's it team's look at them and I
think he could only play in the nickel
guess what base defense is nowadays they
need three corners in Washington they
need to load up on corners so once again
I'll say it I think I meet Robertson I
think in a pinch he could survive on the
outside maybe you don't want him there
full time but he's gonna thrive in a
dime and nickel Rolfe wherever he gets
drafted today and today Matt I mean a
lot of teams instead they'll take
developmental guys on this day but there
are plenty of players on the board that
I actually do think kept starting
potential from day one and I'd like to
hear who do you think the guys that are
left that can play even if it's a number
three wide receiver a slot corner a
nickel backer who do you got yeah you
know I am a big fan of Colin Johnson
from Texas again being a little bit of a
Homer but actually we have the pick is
in at a pick 100 108 overall the
Washington Redskins and I have to hat
tip our day three mock drafts of
bleacher report this morning this was
the pick Sadiq Charles offensive tackle
from LSU sometimes you hear things in
the lead-up to the draft
Washington one of the few teams that did
not call LSU about Sadiq Charles so felt
pretty good about him being the pick
their left tackle and we're gonna do a
video on this one because left tackle
for national championship LSU Tigers we
have to talk about Washington maybe get
in there Trent Williams replacement they
trade him this morning maybe this is the
replacement Connor let's do the video
the Washington Redskins trade shrimp
Williams we say who's gonna play left
tackle let's hear me this guy LSU Sadiq
Charles is the pick at 108 overall an
SEC stud performer Connor a very very
good athlete that's the first thing that
stands out his goodness this guy can
move checks all the boxes but there are
some questions about him making that
transition to the NFL after a suspension
at LSU where'd you have this guy ranked
what do you think about him now
replacing Trent Williams yeah so mad I
really like this player on the field
with the talent I had a third round raid
on him and when you look at where he was
stacked up in this class he was my 10th
rated offensive tackle talent wise he
could have been a guy that sat in the
top six the problem is I talked to teams
after night number two and I said what's
going on with Siddiq Charles he looks
very talented and as you alluded to he's
not on a lot of boards he got wiped off
boards because of off field concerns cuz
a character concerns obviously the
suspension plays into that but the
talent is worth the risk on day three to
me you seem to be able to great feet
great mirror great matching with pass
rushers good anchor really strong anchor
there so for Sadiq Charles he's a guy
they can get outside and move and I look
at it it's worth the risk if you can get
in right Ron Rivera is a very hands-on
coach very players friendly coach I give
this a be because once again the talent
is worth the risk at this point of the
draft yeah absolutely I give it the same
great Abby you're taking a flyer on a
guy who was suspended six games that is
a question but if you can keep him
dialed in you're getting a good left
tackle prospect the Seacoast whose bill
I thought looked more like a round tube
player so Redskins maybe get their left
tackle of the future here in round four
all right a little bit of a surprise
with Trent Larenz being traded didn't
think Nova's gonna happen after it
didn't happen on night one or night two
but now we see that they do get their
hopeful left tackle of the future and
again the suspension is it was big at
LSU they need him to be a much more
consistent much more reliable than he
was in Washington you hope that you get
him in you know veteran leadership
Dwayne Haskins there at quarterback Ron
Rivera coming in Jack Del Rio is the DC
Scott Turner is the OC you hope that you
can get Charles on the field because
like you alluded to Connor when he was
on the field he looks like a starting
left tackle I thought so I mean I had
him 90th overall and I think my only two
concerns were could you get him focus
can you get him to fully commit and the
other thing was he did have short arms
Matt the 33 inch arm so that was gonna
knock him a little bit to the length but
I think what he made up for and lack of
arm length was really really light feet
and that allowed him to mirror the
outside speed rushers in the sec and one
thing you look at his body type and you
get concerned is he gonna struggle
against speed to power and he really
really didn't very often so you see him
on a lot of great zone blocks for Clyde
Edwards a layer he's really really
reliable in pass Perot it's just once
again is this guy gonna show up is he
gonna be ready to go because if he
didn't have the character concerns I
thought he was a lock for the top 50
yeah Connor we have the pick at 109 the
Las Vegas Raiders trade up they select
John Simpson my actual top overall
player in the board this morning
offensive guard from Clemson maybe we
see Gabe Jackson move let's do a video
about the Raiders getting a right guard
in John Simpson
the Las Vegas Raiders are moving in John
Simpson oh he can move the pile at left
guard counter my top overall player
available as we sit here at pic 109 the
Raiders get someone he's gonna be good
in the run game he has protected a
mobile quarterback he's played outside
zone scheme opening things up for Travis
ETN he's great in screen packages I
actually loved the power of John Simpson
to get him a pick 109 one of the bigger
steals in the draft in my opinion for
the Raiders I think so as well I had him
as my 74th overall player and when you
look at somebody that played in an
outside zone scheme you think lighter
body type lighter feet and with Simpson
what stands out is his raw strength and
power the ability of him for him to blow
players off the ball and when you look
at that then you see he can get out in
front and throw his body around which is
very very impressive I think this was
one of the players here today that I had
circled I think he could start from day
one I think is super super powerful
meathook hands and when he latches on to
you he has no problem with driving you
into the ground but you see enough
giddyup also to get out on screens get
out on outside runs a pretty versatile
guard in my eyes Matt and once again one
of my favorite putt players left today I
had a third round great on him I'm gonna
give this one a clear-cut A for those
Las Vegas Raiders a phenomenal pickier
great value people were getting on me on
Twitter saying I was being too easy as a
grater it's staying today a plus mike
Mayock loves him some Clemson Tigers
if gave Jackson has moved you have his
replacement right here in John Simpson
in route for the 2020 draft
alright man mike Mayock just goes to
Death Valley in scouts I don't know if
he goes anywhere else in the country
when he's evaluating players it's just
boom Death Valley
Clemson Tigers who you got next year
maybe it's Trevor Lawrence and mr.
Justin Ross but he loves him some
Clemson guys oh it's crazy
I mean you got a wonder at this point
what they're gonna surrender nine
first-round picks for Trevor Lawrence
next year I mean they are just cleaning
up but they're doing good that's what I
love about the Raiders right now we
laugh at their draft strategy and we're
not poking fun at it sitting here we're
really just laughing at how consistent
they are we know what kind of players
they like they like tough gritty players
I mean the one guy they took that wasn't
from Clemson it feels like Lynn Bowden
was one of the toughest players in all
of college football yeah absolutely and
we'll see what happens here we have pick
we have picked 111 it looks like there's
a little bit of a trade maybe happening
here so 110 the New York Giants are on
the clock as of now I like the Houston
Texans are on the clock yeah the Giants
have taken Darnay homes from UCLA one of
my top slot cornerbacks
but you're available in this class I
love Darnay Darnay holds a little bit
small right a little bit undersized yes
very very good speed you had him on the
stick to football podcast I believe last
week he's feisty at the line of
scrimmage I had one of those dudes talk
about if you were six foot tall I think
we would've heard his name called on
Friday night instead of here on Saturday
morning but the Giants you bring in
corners throughout this process they
drafted John Trey Baker last year they
get James Bradbury in free agency now I
think Darnay Holmes Connor I know you
agree with this I think he is a slot
performer he can play that nickel corner
spot he can lock up in man coverage but
you absolutely love the speed that he
brings to the table like that's you're
looking for a spectacular trait on day
three was something we could build
around when you're evaluating this
prospect when you're projecting him to
the next level well Darnay helps you get
speed that underneath quickness and very
very feisty working you know with those
fast receivers he's gonna see in the
slot without it down and I'm excited to
do this video because another great
Giants pick is they are loading up on
the secondary for Joe judge yeah
absolutely we are gonna do a video
breaking this one down for our g-men
friends
[Music]
the New York Giants have added one of
the toughest fastest quickest corners in
the 2020 draft process journée holds an
attractive boy looks like Willie Mays
out there in center field
Connor Rodgers I know he was one of your
favorite sleepers in this draft class a
little bit undersized but we love the
quickness what he can do working in slot
coverage he can lock up in man he could
play soft zone we saw him there with the
ball skills the instincts a very very
good athlete that we're believing to
just lock up a play matchup on the
inside he absolutely was this is what I
thought was one of the best slot
cornerbacks in this draft when you look
at the RNA Holmes firm former five-star
recruit graduated at UCLA in two and a
half years really got on the field right
away they're really good return ability
as well so when you look at him I mean I
watched him mad I thought this is right
where he would go top up fourth round
and he matches what the Giants have
really done in this trap they're getting
high character players at positions of
need offensive line and in the secondary
they drafted an outside corner and
DeAndre Baker last year they signed one
in James Bradbury and free agency this
year
now Darnay Holmes projects to play on
the inside right away great closing
speed underneath quick twitch on the
ball this is an A and I add a BG man he
put on those new bounces and was ready
to rock this week I absolutely love what
the New York Giants have done this year
yeah I think it's got to be the goatee
I'm giving them an A as well Dave
gentlemen has knocked it out of the park
so far and they're checking off needs
with athletes something we have not
always seen them doing the past of the
New York Giants get a very good one here
in Darnay homes in the fourth round all
right Connor we got a couple picks we'll
get caught up too like we said it's
gonna go fast today at 111 the Miami
Dolphins select Solomon Kinley a guard
from Georgia at 112 the charger select a
running back Joshua Kelly so they lose
Melvin Gordon a free agency not lose
they let him go in free agency they keep
Austin Eckler now they get Joshua Kelly
to replace him and to be that number two
back in this offense yeah I think when
you look at it we knew that they needed
to take a running back eventually at
some point I think when you look at
Austin hecklers body type you actually
are gonna sit there and wonder you know
how much now he's had a crazy workload
as a pass catcher but you didn't need
somebody that can run the ball to split
some carries or take a little bit of the
workload off so Joshua Kelly an
underrated player in this
Matt literally is Halle McKinley again
he could play guard left or right guard
the Dolphins continue to just build a
very mean very physical offensive line
they got Austin Jackson they get Robert
hunt now they get Solomon Kinley so we
think they're going to run the ball a
little bit with Jordan Howard back there
but the big one here is gonna be Joshua
Kelly going to the Los Angeles charge is
kind of we're gonna make a video about
our man going from UCLA to the LA see
the Los Angeles chargers lose Melvin
Gordon this that's right we got Joshua
Kelly right now back yard at UCLA Connor
we saw burst speed from him he is a
physical runner also a very good
receiver out of the backfield
I liked him as one of the sleeper
running backs on day three best
available back on my board actually
where did you have Joshua Kelly going
how do you think he's gonna fit here in
LA yeah so I thought he was gonna be
more of a sixth or a seventh round pick
here Matt I had a couple running backs
ahead of him on my board like II know
Benjamin Anthony McFarland even jabón
League DJ Dallas but when you look at
Kelly a tough runner I think he's got
more lateral ability than we thought
yeah that hurdle there you could see it
I mean this guy had a very very
productive career at UCLA when the
program wasn't exactly high-flying so I
think that speaks to his character it
speaks to how hard of a runner he is
once again I thought the change of
direction was pretty solid here and it
fits with the Chargers need when you
look at it they need a back that can
take the ball right away and spell
Austin Eckler so once again some better
running backs on my board but this type
of runner if your runner is a good fit
here for the Chargers I'll give it a
b-minus
yeah you saw I'm actually gonna give
this one an a I liked the value of that
like I said top back lifts on the board
for me and they needed a guy a
complementary guy I like they're not
taking running backs in the first round
anymore so not gonna see maybe a huge
fantasy impact but a nice complementary
back for Austin Eckler who looks to be
the dude for the Chargers next year
running back
all right we are flying Connor it feels
good to be on day three man where we are
way ahead of where my TV is right now at
least so we are cooking and still good
players left on the board and I think
one of the major questions is where do
these quarterbacks come off where do we
see a Jacob Eason nobody would see Jake
from injurious write that no one wants
them well the one that surprises me here
Matt I think we're gonna hear his name
soon would be Jake Fromm
you got one yeah we got one here so pick
one 13 the Carolina Panthers the team of
losers James Bradbury they get a quarter
in Troy pride junior from Notre Dame
someone we saw at the Senior Bowl those
gold helmets pop and mobile but our guy
looked very very good
we had his coach Brian Kelly on the
podcast in the booth that week we'll
break it down in a video here for you
Panthers fans because you just got one
heck of a player
the Carolina Panthers had a need at
cornerback will they go get one and
round for who we believe he's gonna see
the field early and can play some ball
troy fried junior only getting better at
the corner position saw him develop at
Notre Dame so I have an outstanding
senior Bowl week and process his head
coach brian kelly loves troy pride
junior that is good enough for me it's
good enough for matt rule the Carolina
Panthers
I like the physicality here someone
Connor who come up will challenge guys
in the catch point big enough 511 193
with four four zero speed he's gonna
take away those comeback routes and he
can run down the field with these
receivers he's gonna see in the NFC
South that's right Matt there's a traits
based corner you see the play speed you
see the timing speed it's very good you
see him an off coverage here the ability
to come up and break down and make a
tackle so when you watch him play I
think there's a lot of the little things
right number one his play speed is very
very good I thought he was a good
tackler I think you'd like to see him be
a little more technically sound in
coverage are you gonna ask him to come
up and play press man I didn't see that
I think he's not as sticky as you would
like but when umber one he's a really
really good athlete a very very
coachable athlete and somebody that
probably projects is a number three
corner but one of my top corners
available in this trap especially out of
the guys that ran really well he was the
dude this is a B+ for me yeah I wouldn't
give this one a B Connor
I like the value maybe a little bit of a
reach with some of the corners who were
still on the board but a very very good
fit with what this defense wants to do
and on day three
I'm good rolling the dice on a corner
who runs a 440 flat and has starter size
that's Troy pride junior from Notre Dame
so we're 113 Carolina Panthers take Troy
pride we're gonna be up 114 is going to
be the Arizona Cardinals Kliff Kingsbury
we don't know if he's still chillin in
that amazing house that he was in
earlier in the draft the the Browns are
up at 1:15 the Jags at 116 so some teams
we've had good drafts coming up here the
Arizona Cardinals Connor that we saw
them address the offensive line a little
bit you got Isaiah Simmons where else do
they need to go in this draft not wide
receiver after all the guys they took
last year and then trading for DeAndre
Hopkins there's a lot of different
options they can go we know they have a
ton of bodies in that wide receiver room
they upgraded that offensive line I do
wonder if they go back to that
I look at somebody you know like Nick
Harris who was very very undersized but
moves as well as any Center in this
class he's somebody that I think would
fit their scheme especially if they want
to load up at bodies are they going to
look to add more to their interior
defensive line I know they spent some
money there in the offseason and when it
comes down to it man there's a couple
players I really like lately key foe to
James Lynch do you have the pick yeah we
got the pick here it is that we thought
they'd go defensive tackle in round one
there were a team linked to Derek Brown
a lot right they need a nose tackle they
did go lucky folk to the defensive
tackle that's a great big boy right in
the middle of the field so for our
Cardinals fans friends but we all really
like what they're getting in this nose
tackle from in authorises lad the
Arizona Cardinals missed out on Derek
Brown in round one that's okay and round
four they come back and get portably the
second-best nose tackle the entire track
class leaky boat too from Utah this huge
defense was stacked and he was the man
in the middle complaint nose tackle can
go outside play five technique you're
getting versatility but raw power in the
middle of this line you want to free
people up you have Isaiah Simmons and
Chandler Jones now on defense Connor
free them up to make plays that's what
this big man is gonna do on the D line
yeah they might need to make those
hallways a little wider at the Cardinals
facility with the size of this lad but I
mean talk about eating space running a
hot motor playing very very hard
creating pressure at that size mat they
didn't just sit him at the 0 or sit him
at the 1 and say okay you're gonna clog
two gaps at all times you're really
gonna hold all these offensive linemen
they let him go at times and pin his
ears back and get upfield and you see it
right there that's a disruptive play
shooting gaps at that size I was really
impressed just an old school looking
player and absolute mammoth but somebody
that I thought gave more pass-rush
juice than giving credit for the
Cardinals needed help on the interior I
thought this was a third round pet
player I absolutely loved the pig I'm
giving this one an A for Arizona whoo
they've had some really good value picks
in this draft so far an A all the way
for the cards yeah I'm right there with
you an a as well maybe the Arizona
Cardinals you get a starting nose tackle
at the top of the fourth round this
could be a Brandon Williams type
the Arizona Cardinals that I dance of
Liman totally totally on board with
Steve Kahn continuing to have a very
good 2020 draft class all right we are
ahead here kind of the Cleveland Browns
115 they sign Austin Hooper in free
agency with the Browns have selected
Harrison Bryant a tight end from FIU not
hunter Bryant from Washington
Harrison Bryant the Macky Award winner
from Florida International let's make a
video for the dog pound the Cleveland
Browns they're gonna throw the ball in
the middle of the field they get
Harrison Bryant the macula Ward winner
tight in from Florida International
University he can play inline flex tight
in we've seen him line up at fullback
but dominated a lesser level of
competition then he goes to the Senior
Bowl and stands out there Bryant was my
number three tight end in this class
Conner where they gave it around for his
exceptional value and my favorite thing
about this is you have Austin Hooper and
now you have Bryant so where you're
gonna line these tight ends up you have
complete versatility on offense yeah I
see eye to eye with you on this player
Matt I had him as my third tight end as
well and I had him at the top of round
four so when you look at it this is a
fit this is a good value this is a
player that I have to you know be honest
here I was a little disappointed with
the testing numbers I was disappointed
with the testing numbers at the NFL
Combine but when you look at it I
thought this place feed was decent I
thought he has pretty pretty good hands
he's a short area target so this is a B
for me with the Browns I think they have
enough help at this position already but
this might be one of those players where
you develop in behind Austin Hooper and
then 2 years you're looking to free up
money you go man we got the same guy
already so it could be a good value pick
down the road alright got our I said
Florida International instead of Florida
Atlantic because I don't know my
Florida's very well so we're gonna
restart that now that I actually
remember what college is Scott well I
apologize you were great just do
everything you just did we'll do that
one again
FAU not if I you alright I don't I don't
any Lane Kiffin mad at me today over
stand the wrong thrown Florida school so
he doesn't care anymore he's on to the
next one
the Cleveland Browns select the Macky
Award winner Harrison Bryant at tight in
here ox number 40 Connor he could play H
back pull back tight end line him up
wherever you want you now have Odell
Beckham jr. Jarvis Landry Austin Hooper
gift cream hutnik Chuck Baker Mayfield
has to be the happiest man on the planet
right now because his general manager is
getting him some weapons in my number
three tight end in this year's class I
see eye to eye with you on this one Matt
my number three tight end as well I had
him really coming off the board at the
top of round for a short area target I
think when you look at it like you said
you can play him really an h-back
fullback tight ends good hands not the
best athlete in the world I think that's
what disappointed me I just wonder you
know at that size I think you can move a
little bit better but when you look at
the Browns this feels like a value pick
where you develop in behind Austin
Hooper and you hope that you have depth
now behind Austin Hooper and maybe if
you want to free up some money down the
line two years from now this guy becomes
their next version of that middle of the
field pass catcher so for the Browns
here I like the value
I like this player in a really really
poor tight end class this is a be right
here for the good old Cleveland Browns
I bet draft star for Andrew berry here
in this new era yeah I'm gonna give this
in a I like the versatility no he's not
even your number one tight end he's
probably your fifth option in the
passing game but the value is
exceptional and they continue to get
guys who produced in college we saw that
in round one so every pick they've been
in this draft high character producers
Harrison Bryant goes to the Cleveland
Browns alright buddy we are at 116 the
Jacksonville Jaguars select bin Barch
the offensive tackle from st. John's
that's a Minnesota in case anybody was
wondering he's being projected as guard
it's what text I just received they
think he's gonna kick inside maybe play
some guards a small school lineman comes
off the board the Vikings are on the
clock at 1:17 then we have the Broncos
at 118 Falcons at 119 so not a lot of
surprises so far some players at the top
of the big board have not come off we've
talked a lot about why are the
quarterbacks falling with Eason sounds
like there's some you know you call
character attitude concerns with Jake
from lack of traits even though high
football IQ and he's interviewing very
well the quarterbacks are still out
there but otherwise that this is really
continuing what we saw on day one at
8:00
this draft is just going as we expected
it to yeah I think so I mean all the
really good players are coming off the
board or the guys that have starter
potential I still think there's talent
at the top of this corner group right
now that's the one where I'm kind of
wondering you know when is somebody
gonna take the roll the dice on a Brice
Hall a meek Robertson to me was a
phenomenal player that I think I mean I
had a late second round great on so
that's my big father of the year so far
and then when you look at it the
offensive lineman you know we talked
about been Barch going to Jacksonville
he's somebody that I thought should be
developed as a tackle I don't know if he
has the place strength to survive inside
and if you want to know anything about
bartsch read up on the smoothie this guy
takes the game weight I think it gave
him like 80 pounds throughout his
conscious come here wait wait you see
the top players on the board here Matt
one guy I want to ask you about that we
could here go very soon
Stanford Samuels the third from Florida
State what are you thinking for him
today yeah I think he comes up the board
very very early big just did not run
very well at 465 but we actually have
the next pick 117 the Minnesota Vikings
they need an edge rusher they get one at
dj1 I'm from South Carolina so they're
attacking their needs two corners in
this draft they get Justin Jefferson so
first of their 13 picks today 13 picks
for experiment the Saints on the other
hand none Sean Payton's done Mickey
Loomis is done
they're just chillin today but the
Vikings 13 picks we're gonna make a
video for our friends up north
dj1 I'm going there we'll edge rusher
the Minnesota Vikings need to get
younger at the edge rusher position and
oh baby did they with DJ wanna from
South Carolina 65 258 ran a 473 in the
40-yard dash my comp for this gentleman
Romeo o Quora who he's gonna see
opposite him with the Detroit Lions
Connor I loved DJ one of his tape as a
round for round five edge rusher who has
some traits that can be developed
obviously Daniel hunters on one side
you're good there but ever sing Gryphon
not in the long-term plans here now you
have a player in round four that we
think could be a developmental guy yeah
that's exactly what he is man I saw some
explosiveness on tape I think you like
the overall build body type and size of
wanna my question for me is real
can he get better at being a power
rusher because I don't think he has
enough Bend on the outside to survive as
a pure speed rusher so when you look at
it experience standing up read react get
down hill closed he does all of that my
only problem here Matt and I wonder if
you agree I think there's better players
on the board I like Bradley and I I like
Kenny Willa kiss Alton Robinson Curtis
Weaver even Khalid Kareem Travis Gipson
so that's my problem of why listen I
love everything the Vikings do this one
not for me see - I thought there was
better edge players on the board but
every time the Vikings take a draw
talented edge they develop them better
than anyone else so it scares me to give
my first bad grade of the day right B -
for me I agree value was a little bit
off with the players who were still on
the board round four is about where you
expected this player to come off but the
Vikings they owned day one and day two
one of the big winners of the draft
first pick and round four one of many a
little bit of a surprise for us all
right pick one 18 is the Denver Broncos
last year they got its in drew lock from
quarter quarterback from Missouri
this year they get his tight end Connor
and I'm gonna let you try to say his
name if you want to attack this one yeah
this is the only name in the draft that
I will not try to say and I practiced
for like 30 minutes one day and I
already forgot so Alberto from Missouri
the speedster at tight end and I think
we definitely need to make a video for
this one this is a pic that makes a lot
of sense when you look at the Broncos
roster okwait bounnam's I will never use
that again your one-hit wonder
all right we are ready let's make a
video the Denver Broncos continue to
load up on athletes for drew Locke in
this class they go get his old tight in
Albert Oakley bounnam from Mizzou ran a
4 for 9 at 65 258 pounds he is a
vertical threat a seam buster at tight
end had a little trouble staying healthy
at Mizzou that's the biggest question
here can he stay on the field that's why
when you see that size and speed profile
he's still on the board in round 4 but
my goodness if this player can stay
healthy Connor Rodgers he can be special
yeah if you could build the tight end
this is probably what he would look like
and this pick is for one reason Matt you
are getting a backup to know a fan that
has the speed to do exactly what they
want up the scene that's what Alberto
does best and guess what you get to see
it right here as he gets off a light
press and tracks the ball and brings it
in I think what Alberto when he was on
the field he was a pretty solid pass
catcher did some really nice work in the
red zone the injuries are a bit of a
concern the production it wasn't great I
think he's very very slow after the
catch for a guy that has such good speed
without the ball in his hands but this
is clearly just providing more depth
behind no offense in case he gets hurt
so for Alberto and the Broncos my only
problem with this there's a better
version of him on the board in Hunter
Bryant's so I give this a C+ I'm not
convinced he could stay healthy at the
next level right now you know I'm gonna
give it a a the health is concerned but
I like taking the chance on the athlete
because if he does he is going to be
special and they're too tight and set
might be unguardable the Broncos
continue to add weapons to this offense
trying to keep up with those Kansas City
Chiefs
all right Connor here is a message from
our presenting sponsor rocket mortgage
by Quicken Loans big special shout out
to all the essential workers out there I
want to say thank you to my sister joy
thank you thank you thank you sir
[Music]
thank you again to rocket mortgage you
can join them everyone knows a hero com
leave your message thanking essential
work or something hopefully we all can
make time to do sweet of time the
Atlanta Falcons on the clock 119 overall
we've seen them be aggressive so far in
this draft they get a corner in round
one they still have needs on defense
well I look at Atlanta we've seen we've
seen a run on defenders but they still
have needs whether that's the defensive
tackle another edge rusher someone in
the safety position could be a big area
for them Connor so the Falcons we love
our guy Tom dimitrov how he builds teams
but they do need to continue to add to
court a one corner AJ Tom a Tennessee
sarva that is a center Moreland Davidson
defensive lineman from Auburn he's gonna
play next to Grady Jarrett but they
could go edge here Dante Fowler jr. does
come in they have tack McKinley a former
first-round pick on the opposite side I
wouldn't be surprised to see a safety
come off the board here for Atlanta or
even a number three wide receiver with
Julio Jones starting get a little bit
older yeah they have a lot of options
here I mean we've talked about Bradley
and I I think when you look at cabe on
Wallace he's somebody that really really
fits what they asked for on that defense
so they a guy that can handle a lot of
different roles somebody that I find
very interesting that will come off the
board today Matt Kenny Robinson from the
XFL a really good cover play making
safety that was a first-team all-big 12
guy at West Virginia in 2018 so for the
Falcons here
I would think defense all the way on
this side but Dimitrov likes to take a
running back on day three every single
year of the draft so you never really
know and it is a linebacker on defense
of Fresno State's Michael Walker so
they're getting 6-3 250-pound linebacker
be completely honest i hemmed had him
great at round six or around seven so a
reach where they're taking him but
understand they want to get someone who
can stop the run he is a big physical
linebacker who will step up have those
run fits put him in there with Deon
Jones and now your linebacker core
starting to round out a little bit so a
lot of defense we've seen the corner
lead alignment and now a linebacker you
do wonder like sit dementia off loves
running backs is smart to take a
receiver on day three in the draft if
you can so still room for them to plug
in some of those other holes that we
have looking at who's of
and who's on the board 120 Connor is
time for the J ETS jet gesture we're
gonna ride out of this spot yeah we're
gonna get a run with the Jets I think
they picked three times Matt in the next
nine picks oh I hope you're not set
right you might pick 129 that's right
you might team not picking today the San
Francisco 49ers your team making all the
picks today the judge the Michael Walker
pick is the most Falcons thing ever they
take one of these light linebackers that
moves well in space every single year
absolutely here's best available for
your jets
Bryce hull definitely intriguing do you
get Sam Donald another weapon and a
Dodman people's Jones or Hunter Bryant
we have not seen them have a lot of
success the tight in position at least
not consistently and then we check out
the quarterbacks hanging out there but
where do you want your jets to go like
you said three picks in the next nine
what are you hoping to attack here so
for me I would go with one of the three
top guys right there and I know that
sounds simple but they're areas of need
a Mika Robertson Brian pools on a
one-year deal you still need a slot
Corner Bradley and I you still need all
the pass rush help in the world there is
no doubt about that
Brice Hall you can develop him on the
outside Pierre Desir is on a one-year
deal you can make Brice Hall a girafft
and stash player for 2021 give him some
reps like they did with less on Austin
at the end of this year who also flashed
so when Joe Douglas all options are on
the table I wouldn't mind them going
back to wide receiver again with Donovan
peoples Jones I even like Isaiah Hodgins
a lot today a name that we have not
brought up might have the best hands in
the draft map scene you say a lot of
good things about him as well there's a
lot of good players on the board here
for the Jets do you double dip a line
because there are some interior
offensive linemen who've fallen here a
little bit and that I know you some of
you know I've talked about a lot over
the past couple months
the Jets could take five linemen and be
okay they can take three receivers and
be okay
did you take two corners and be ok so
they have a lot of needs across the
board I don't know if there's one that
stands out more than any other looking
at the guys who are available like you
said Isaiah Hodgins I like a lot Colin
Johnson from Texas probably not a fit
now because they took Denzel Mims same
for Antonio Gandy golden from Liberty a
small school favorite of the folks who
follow the draft on Twitter what about
somebody like
Gabe Davis who I cop to Quincy and noon
law get another receiver another bigger
player but not so much like Denzel names
I think more of a possession type player
yeah and a very productive player at UCF
I saw them win down the field but I
don't think that'll be this game at the
next level like you said a possession
kind of player I think he has a really
good big body to shield from defenders
to catch the ball so Gabe Davis is
somebody that would be in my eyes not a
big ceiling pick but a high floor pick
and a lot of the receivers were looking
at today matchup with that now I have
Gabe Davis right at the top of the fifth
round Connor I got that pick for you
buddy let's am I gonna let your you
sound kind of excited I apologize I
don't mean to cut you off but I want to
give you the pick it is a running back
from Florida with Michael P Ryan we saw
his brother play oh you a couple years
back so the Jets go running back with P
Ryan big physical back to go a levy on
bail we got to make a video for your
jets I'm excited to hear your grade the
look on your face maybe gives it away
but I'm excited to hear done here right
yeah you look like ah nope not great
okay let's do a video here about the
Michael P ride to the Jets Looney or
just continue to add playmakers for Sam
Dartmouth and now you get a running back
from Florida who has power with a
breakaway speed let Michael P Rhine he
has power he has hands if you're gonna
draft someone to maybe replace Le'Veon
Bell or at least spell ahem Connor this
is your team we saw here I'm play in
person once this year at the Senior Bowl
how do you like this for Joe Douglas at
the top around four I think it's very
early Matt when I look at P Ryan I had
him in the seventh round I don't really
see the great breakaway speed I think
he's an older player a running back now
there is burst there and I think is the
Jets really commit to an outside zone
that's what they're looking for you see
it right on the option here a really
funky option the Harris ago but when you
watch this for him he's a guy that you
really want probably in that zone
blocking scheme they're gonna look to
get more athletic on the offensive line
I do think you like what he can do as a
pass catcher so maybe that's what
they're invested in here now when you
talk about replacing levy on bail that's
my question here I don't think P Ryan is
enough I don't think he's a guy that you
know they're gonna be looking to move on
from Bell in 2021 to free up that cap
space there were a lot better players on
the board I think you know Benjamin was
the premium version of what P Rhine does
so this is a C for me not my favorite
pic of the day right there with you I
have a 169 overall the value is quite a
bit off I like Joe Douglas I like what
they're trying to do in New York by
getting a running back in her up for but
a little bit of a reach in our opinion
for LaMichael
P Ryan to the Jay ETS just just Jets all
right Connor at 1:21 the Detroit Lions
in the most typical Detroit Lions pick
of the weekend Logan Steinberg offensive
lineman from Kentucky could play tackle
could play guard big that visible not a
great athlete that is the most Lions
offensive line pick I have ever seen in
my life yeah we are video we just rock
and roll we are gonna know we're gonna
make a video for this guy the Lions are
here we got it we got a rep Detroit item
in the fourth round that's okay
excited to hear your grade I know you're
not the largest fan of the truck the
Detroit Lions let's do a video here
Connor yeah let's do it
the Detroit Lions they want to build
something mean and nasty up front you
get one of the meanest nastiest players
on the offensive line in the 2020 NFL
Draft Logan Steinberg from Kentucky
excellent size strength a Muller in the
trenches not a lot of athleticism I am
excited to see where do you move someone
who at 660 3:17 did not have that
lateral agility to maybe excel it guard
can he stay at tackle where do you put
Logan Steinberg on the lines offensive
line oh he's an interior offensive
lineman all the way Matt he is going to
play guard now a little slow a foot is
my big problem with Stenberg but for the
Lions they are looking for someone that
lines up across from you and can down
block and you could see the power in the
hands he can drive you out of the way
that's what I like about stemberg a lot
I add him in the fourth round so I think
the value aligns here and once again if
you feel good enough about the center
you have next to him to aid him in pass
protection I think
he gives you enough in the run game with
those strong strong hands so like you
said size power good run blocker would
like to see him get a little bit of help
in pass pro but in the fourth round
that's expected at the guard position
this is so typical Lyons they love these
phone booth guys on the interior
offensive line every year especially
after round one so I'm gonna go with the
B it's really not a bad pick and I think
he fits the profile of what they look
for yeah we gotta say we're not sharing
notes I promise a b-minus for me I do I
value is good and the fit is exactly
what they want they've lost some players
knee tear off into blind the free agency
now you get someone would not be
surprised at all if he's not starting in
his rookie year for the Detroit Lions
alright and we can say Connor now that
Joe Staley is expected to retire
according to Adam Schefter the Colts are
on the clock right now at pick 122 but
Joe Staley expected to retire
six-time Pro Bowler all-decade offensive
tackle one of my absolute favorite 49ers
of all time I'm actually a little bit
sad about this but it sounds like health
concerns and again mentioned this at the
top of the show today he's 35 years old
he's hinted at this for about two years
that he might be ready to retire 2019 it
felt like you just got a bonus year for
a guy who maybe didn't want to play so
this sets emotion Trent Williams
becoming a San Francisco 49er yeah what
a throw to you Matt cuz obviously this
is a team you're very close to I feel
like you've had a lot of inside info on
this team for a while when you look at
Staley were they prepared for this
because this is late notice to get this
do you think they were working behind
the scenes maybe they were quietly
watching the tackle class quietly or not
so quietly watching the Trent Williams
trade market was this something the
Niners had on their minds not just this
week but for a month now yeah absolutely
last week in the lead-up to the draft
there were definitely rumblings of if
they stay at 13 would they take a tackle
is Tristan wharfs the target is Makai
Becton a target so there were rumblings
that tackle was going to be a need and
actually doing the media circuit
pre-draft anytime I did some in the Bay
Area they'd be like tell us about the
tackles because this might be a need so
the beat reporters out there we're
definitely on top of this one want to
give them a lot of credit cuz they
really got this news moving so the
Niners I think as a Niners fan and to
the
to my Niner fam friends out there this
is probably your best case scenario if
Joe Staley wanted to retire if there are
health concerns if he wants to walk away
from football while he can
that's awesome he should be able to do
it and you replace him with Trent
Williams who in 2018 I think was the
best left tackle in football now he took
a year off because a contract disputes
with the Redskins as long as he can
bounce back you got to feel really good
today that you are not getting a drop
off of left tackle no you're not it's as
simple as that I think when you look at
Trent Williams he's somebody that is
gonna come in and if he's right Matt
he's clearly an upgrade I'm for a team
that just wants to run the ball non-stop
his athleticism his raw power I mean the
guy was basically impossible to get
around in pass probe so when you look at
Trent you know I think he's gonna be
right I'm actually buying into the
comeback for Trent Williams after the
year off where maybe his body is feeling
even better Conner Rodgers had picked
122 overall the Indianapolis Colts have
selected Jacob Eason quarterback
Washington a player that they had been
connected to in round two of this draft
Jacob Eason to the Colts we are going to
do a video I cannot wait for your
response to see your grade let's get
into it
the Indianapolis Colts they bring in
Phillip Rivers they put Jacoby burr sat
on the bench but they do not have a
quarterback under contract for 2021
now they do Jacob Eason from Washington
you may remember him from Georgia a
five-star recruit coming out of high
school the biggest arm in this draft
class in my opinion this man can launch
it down the field the beauty of this you
are not rushing him to get on the field
right now had to take that 2018 season
off because of transfer rules he used to
sit behind Papa Phil do you sit behind
Jacoby Brissette no pressure for Eason
he can develop Chris Ballard and Frank
Reich getting themselves a little bit of
a project in round four Connor sure but
I had a round three great on him Matt so
I like the value here when you look at
Eason a gigantic gigantic arm there is
no doubt about that all the talent in
the world really now what you see here
is him simply can throw the ball a mile
and he could throw it accurately down
the field where he struggled was
throwing under pressure when that
Washington offensive line gave him time
this is what he did he picked apart
secondaries over and over again and he's
not somebody that's a check down Charlie
now this guy is somebody that will push
the ball on the intermediate level on
the deep level he can throw a touch when
he needs to I think for the Colts the
fact that they sat and waited this long
and still got Eason this is a really
good landing spot for him in an offense
where he's gonna have time to sit he's
not gonna have to play this year it's
clearly a redshirt year for Jacob Eason
this is an a-minus cuz I like the value
and I like the talent at this late in
the draft yeah a plus I thought they
could have taken a quarterback at 34
overall or with one of their
second-round picks one of their
third-round picks they wait till round
four they get a player I had valued at
number 66 overall on live boards so I
love the value I like that they're
taking someone who can't like sit sit
develop wait we'll see what he can do in
2021 with no pressure on Jacob Eason to
perform a great landing spotting a great
pick for the Indianapolis Colts all
right so just the run on quarterback
start Jake from is still out there do we
see Jake go but Jacob Eason really
really good value and this is what you
talk at Chris Ballard this is what he
does we've seen him since 2017 as the
general manager in Indianapolis they got
Malik Hooker his first year they get
Quentin Nelson they just take value
picks without panicking without reaching
Sion's they really intrigued you fit
there they trade their first rounder for
DeForest Buckner you got to add him in
to the hole they've seen this year they
got Michael Pittman they had Jonathan
Taylor it's a very good draft with guys
who like these are picks for the future
running back wide receiver quarterback
they can now grow together yeah we got
it down and I think once again Matt
they're striking on value I thought
Jonathan Taylor and Michael Pittman were
round one players about Eason was a
round three player I think when you look
at it you know Frank Reich in that
offense maybe they wanted somebody that
after the Philip Rivers there and we
didn't see it from Jacobi percent either
somebody that can clearly just sit there
and throw the ball down the field a
little more and once again they can
simplify things for him he can go there
he can work behind the scenes he's not
ever gonna be in a role where Phillip
Rivers gets hurt or looks you know a
step slower as we've seen over the year
where he's gonna they're gonna call for
Eason so I think you needed a landing
spot where he was quarterback number
three and this was the ideal one yep we
have a pick of the Dallas Cowboys at 123
go defense with Reggie Robinson the
second from Tulsa he's giving list at a
corner we actually had him graded at
safety here at bleacher report let's
make a little video for our Dallas
Cowboy fan friends
the Cowboys needed defense Connor Byron
Jones leaves for the Miami Dolphins they
get one in Reggie Robinson the second
from Tulsa Jerry Jones loves the state
of Oklahoma in this NFL Draft
they're getting versatility and athlete
somebody could play nickel safety he
could play nickel corner maybe even see
him on the outside Connor what do you
think of Reggie Robinson and the Cowboys
move to get a defensive back here in
round four yeah so I look at it it's a
little early for him Matt now I loved
the size and speed profile of Reggie
Robinson he's somebody that was
obviously gonna be drafted with that
size speed profile the amount of years
he's played and I think when you look at
it he can offer a lot of different
things in coverage I actually think he
can survive on the outside if you ask
him to my only problem with this pick is
I think there are better outside corners
on the board Stanford Samuels Brice Hall
AJ Green and the list really goes on and
on here so it's not a bad pick because I
think he could develop into you know a
number three kind of player but it's a
c-plus just because it feels a little
early for him I expected him to go in
the sixth round of today's draft
yeah I gave it a B - I like the
athleticism four four four speed six one
two oh five the versatility like I said
we were gonna rank we rank them as
safety the Cowboys listing him at corner
Reggie Robinson the second from Tulsa
just going down i-35 now to the Dallas
Cowboys those little geography nuggets
you're gonna get on day three of the NFL
Draft a bleacher report you're probably
not getting on ESPN today no that's
right I mean we will give you all the
facts and we're gonna talk about all the
picks I think on ESPN they move too fast
they get fixated on what happened the
last two days man and and there's gonna
be there's a lot of good players left
still I think we've seen some reaches
now as we got halfway through the fourth
round it feels like let's take a look at
the last five picks because they have
come off fast furious let's get you
caught up the Atlanta Falcons linebacker
Michael Walker the New York Jets running
back Michael P Ryan the Lions went off
in some guard logins ten burn the Colts
get the quarterback in Jacob Eason and
the Dallas Cowboys get Reggie Robinson I
mentioned it Jerry Jones loves Oklahoma
City lamb double Gallimore Reggie
Robinson Jerry told his area scouts do
not bother me this weekend he's just a
hand in Oklahoma that's all he's only
yeah he's picking picking Sooners he's
doing his thing and you look at all
these picks they all match up I mean
Mike quell Walker with the Falcons
obviously a linebacker that's undersized
but moves well in space lamech open you
know P Ryan is somebody that was a
captain at Florida a high character
player that's a pass catcher that
screams Joe Douglas all the way the
Lions getting a phone booth guard I mean
we're seeing GM's truly stick to their
roots here on the top of day three today
yeah pick 124 the Philadelphia excuse me
the Pittsburgh Steelers 125 the New York
Jets 126 the Rams in that funky logo
that I'm never gonna get used to 127 our
guy left Co not with us today
his Eagles up a 127 so that they've had
one of the most curious traps I think
Joe and rhaegar and round furious - I'm
running out of jail ins for them to
draft here but I think there there has
to be one somewhere that they can get
maybe a corner so we got a couple teams
a couple good teams coming up on the
clock the Jets up again 125 the Steelers
Jake Fromm is not a fit for this offense
chase Claypool Alex Highsmith
get an edge they get like super
encounter they take a running back
anthony mcfarland jr from neither like
that picture bug
running back we were calling him little
booger
hat tip burger mcfarland and i do like
this fit a lot James Connor has been
injured he's been inconsistent now you
get at least a complimentary back
someone who can come and catch out of
the backfield he tore up the Texas
Longhorns when they played so a little
bit jaded toward little booger but heck
of a player let's make a video for the
pittsburgh steelers and anthony
mcfarland the pittsburgh steelers needed
more weapons on offense they got chased
Claypool now they get Anthony McFarland
jr. from Maryland like hot for him
Connor Rogers Duke Johnson 444 speed at
5-8 208 very good hands out of the
backfield look a short is the jitterbug
though this guy's hard to tackle in
space and he does have that deep speed
to run away from defenses insanely
elusive Matt insanely elusive and like
you said it can be effective as a pass
catcher but when they got this guy going
on the outside he had big play threat
written all over him and when you look
at that Steelers backfield they have
straightaway power but this is what they
needed they needed somebody that can
create yards after contact or just be
elusive enough to not even get contact
points so you see that one cut and go
kind of move from mcFarland and once
again a guy that can catch a lot of
passes a guy that can be a returner you
can do a lot of different things for
your offense and for your special teams
he was one of my favorite running backs
on the board and I had him right here
with the fourth round great this is an
a-minus this is a really really strong
pick for the Steelers that'll help them
right away yeah I'm gonna be the value
is absolutely perfect out of 65 grade on
Anthony McFarland so where you came in
round for really good value and again
with James Connor not being the most
consistent not being the most reliable
because injuries now you get someone who
can step in and fill that role in round
four for the Pittsburgh Steelers alright
Pittsburgh gets another offensive weapon
they've got a lot of speed in this draft
chase Claypool very fast offensive
weapon Anthony McFarland very fast
running back receiver out of the
backfield wherever you want to play them
whatever you need him to do
ben roethlisberger getting the weapons
and I say it like that because you know
Aaron Rodgers is upset they don't get
him any weapons they've the Packers
traded up for a quarterback and then
drafted basically a fullback for him
it's nice to see these general managers
giving their quarterbacks weapons where
you have a little bit of a Super Bowl
window you got to believe the big bins
back the Steelers you got a pass rusher
and Alex Highsmith that's gonna help in
that rotation but now they do have some
weapons yeah I thought so I thought that
was an area they could have even gone in
the second round but if you know the
Steelers they're not a team that'll
always go that early for running back
they will look later at time so I think
they're you know chasing value here and
I think mcFarland once again brings a
different skill set to the table for
them a guy that can play right away he's
been at Maryland he's been very very
productive he's never gonna be your 1a
kind of runner he's really you're your
second running back that's a third down
pass catcher but the burst is phenomenal
and your New York Jets are back on the
clock at pick 25 overall yeah it's gonna
happen a lot today the Jets the Vikings
the Dolphins have a lot of picks the
Patriots I know Bill Belichick's dog is
drafting today or if it's actually him
we will let you know when we know this
but the Jets on the clock Connor they
went running back with P Ryan from
Florida we talked about it earlier it
feels like corner is a need that has to
be addressed at some point in this draft
for your New York football Jets I think
so and I think honestly the the guys
available in that position group are
some of the best players on the board
today so when you look at it they
doubled up you know I'm very curious
Matt something you handed out yesterday
where are they gonna play Ashton Davis
then they want to get him ready to start
at safety next to Jamal Adams if Marcus
Mae leaves in free agency or do they
want to transition him to corner I think
what they do with these next two fourth
rounders that are in a five rant a five
radius pick here is gonna tell you a lot
yeah it absolutely is and also Jamal
Adams has not been traded you have to
think that he is at least in their plans
for 2020 as of now hopefully they can
get something locked up long term with
the leader of the team but this is a
club that has a couple needs that still
need addressed even after they've had a
very need-based draft even while
sticking to some value first around they
get Makai Becton loved that pick second
round they get Denzel Mims giving Sam
darn 'old a weapon but they could go
anywhere would tighten surprise you with
Chris Herndon struggling a little bit in
2000
19 the only reason it would a little bit
here Matt is because you look at they
gave Ryan Griffin some money they have
Chris Herndon there I do wonder are they
just gonna load up on that room so the
pic yeah please don't look at your
laptop because I want your true or -
into this okay I'm not gonna look at it
at pic 125 Conor Rogers New York Jets
take James Morgan quarterback FIU
I absolutely love that pic this was
somebody I want right there you go today
he was my favorite day three quarterback
so an over jiggy frosty I really that
that is a surprise
is this like that's where I'm that is
where I'm surprised I forgot Jake from
Amazon right word that's interesting we
will do this video yeah absolutely have
to do the video we will pull it this was
your day three guy your day three
quarterback that you liked in this class
we all picked a sleeper quarterback
instant so here's my surprise I like
James Morgan and this is the tough part
like when you don't like a pic but you
like the player I like James Morgan a
lot he has a very good arm
he needs to develop a little bit but
pick 125 you're usually expecting that
player to at least contribute if not
play a lot of snaps early in their
career Jets have a toe can come back he
might have to contribute yeah maybe has
to all right we were gonna make a video
for the Jets this is gonna be a fun
grade to look out for both of us I think
[Music]
the New York Jets they have Sam Donald
what we saw him lose some time last year
to an illness now you get a good backup
in James Morgan from Florida
International Connor Rodgers on stick to
football past week you told us he was
your day three sleeper at quarterback
the arm talent is there albeit
inconsistent but he's not gonna have to
get on the field right away barring
injury the Jets needed a backup
quarterback they take one to pick one 25
that's the odd part to me 125 and he
goes ahead of Jake from from Georgia but
as a Jets fan how you feeling about this
one
well number one I really like James
Morgan he was my favorite day three
quarterback I didn't think Jake Fromm
would make it to day three now he is the
exact opposite of Jake from let's get
that this guy
not Playsafe he's not just your
drop-back passer and high IQ guy he is a
backyard football player the mechanics
are all over the place the arm strength
you see it he'll just drop back and
throw off the back foot and lock your
ball baby that's all he does and that's
kind of exciting with James Morgan an
interesting career started at Bowling
Green roller coaster there then really
dominated at his next stop with FIU so
when you watch him play the downfield
passing attack he flourished in that and
for the Jets here they had to get a
quarterback that can be the backup for
Sam Darnell because Donald has missed
time in his first two seasons this is a
B for me Matt he was my next ranked
quarterback after Jake from so I don't
think it's a gigantic reach yes so not a
huge reach on the positional value I'm
giving it a C+ because the Jets this is
not their next biggest need to fill is
the bad water valve spot that big needs
elsewhere all over the offensive line
another wide receiver you could have
gone edge rusher corner I would have
applauded almost any other pick taking a
quarterback at 125 does make you wonder
what they're thinking in terms of how
they're building this roster the Jets
get a backup quarterback in James Morgan
in round four I'm a big Joe Douglas fan
you know this kind of a big fan of their
scouting staff I think it's one of the
better in the NFL and they are going to
hopefully get this thing turned around
but a quarterback at 125 when we've
talked for months about they could take
what I said earlier you can take five
linemen you kick three receivers you
need to edge rushers you need two
corners quarterback this early feels
again good player feels like they're
overthinking this a little bit yeah I
mean I give it a B and you know how much
I really liked the player it would have
been an a if you know Bradley and I is
on the board I think they need help
they're still there's a lot of corners
on the board where they need help I
think once again Jake Fromm is probably
your safer backup but I think they
wanted a guy with more arm strength so
it is questionable the point of the
draft it's interesting it's always hard
Matt we go through this every year when
you really like a player but you're like
man that's one maybe one and a half two
rounds earlier than I would have gone I
pick 126 the Houston Texans trade up we
don't know Bill O'Brien is throwing
anything at his tablet right now but
they take offensive tackle Charlie heck
from North Carolina his dad
Andy heck the
the line coach for the Kansas City
Chiefs so a little bit of NFL bloodlines
there we're gonna make a video for the
Texans because they don't have our
meeting draft picks they've they've
traded all their other players and all
their picks so we'll do a video for the
Texans Bill O'Brien gets himself a swing
tackle
[Music]
the Houston Texans have learned me
Tunsil they gave him a ton of money they
drafted Titus Howard in the first round
last year now they get Charley heck and
offensive tackle from North Carolina is
dad Andy old line coach for the Kansas
City Chiefs the technique is there the
body type is there I think you can
actually fill out his frame a little bit
Connor what I liked about him most was
the athleticism is very good for an
offensive tackle we could see him be a
swing player maybe move inside play some
offensive guard but again you know the
football IQ is gonna be there you know
the techniques good his dad's one of the
best line coaches in the entire NFL yeah
this seems like a you know a high floor
very low upside pick here Matt when you
look at it I still think there's a lot
of better offensive linemen on the board
which makes you know this a bit of a
surprise here you have someone like Alex
Taylor if you want to tackle or you know
Prince tega wanna go if you want an
interior you have Tyler of about to be a
dish so when I look at this pick here
yeah I don't want to call it a head
scratcher because I think he can
absolutely play and I think the
technique is very very refined I just
wonder you know the level of athlete
you're getting in this spot and once
again it goes back to a lot of the picks
today it just feels like maybe two
rounds early so it's a see for me with
Charlie heck yeah I give it a b-minus I
like Charlie heck I do feel like it's
too early in the draft for him to be
selected and also this is not what you
consider a weakness for the Houston
Texans they've invested in the offensive
line so Charlie heck taking a swing
tackle that third tackle it's a valuable
position maybe a little bit early I pick
126 overall all right we are moving
along the board the Eagles are on the
clock at 127 followed by the bills bills
mafia 128 the Jets at 129 in the
Minnesota Vikings at 130
so as we get into round 4 I'm still
surprised that jake from is on the board
and James Morgan is off it and I ready
to keep saying that like I like James
Morgan but Jake from left Georgia early
and he's still on the board here there
was talk about this man being a top 50
pick this week people were saying top 50
pick four Jake from he's still on the
board the Eagles at 127 I wish our guy
left over here so we could see his
reaction they go cave on Wallace the
safety from Clemson so mike Mayock
doesn't get to draft him because the
Eagles
do but another Clemson defender coming
off the board which just goes to show
how loaded that defense was that took
this team to back-to-back national
championship games came on Wallace and
like all their safeties just versatile
he could play in the Box could play
single high I liked the fact that he
could play really anywhere any of those
safety spots for that defense yeah it's
a phenomenal pick
I mean Kavon Wallace did everything for
that team super super aggressive tough
tackler I mean it's this is I this might
seem crazy but when you combine
everything value need fit this is the
Eagles best pick of the draft all right
we are gonna make a little video for our
Eagles friends so left coking at the
alert on his app and we'll take it away
here the federal the Eagles get another
versatile defender
kVAL Wallace from Clemson he could play
strong safety free safety the size the
speed four or five three in the 40-yard
dash at 511 206 pounds so probably a
nickel player my top for him Connor was
Jordan Richards came out of Stanford a
couple years back number 213 on my board
though so this feels like in my opinion
a reach for the Philadelphia Eagles in
the fourth round yeah I look at Wallace
he does a lot of different things really
really well Matt I actually liked him as
you know a top-ten safety pick player
number 124 on my board once again he can
play as you know a free safety a strong
safety yet slot corner you could shade
him down in the box he'd handle a lot of
different roles at Clemson I think he
was a very very well liked player by the
coaching staff obviously a senior ball
player as well so this is an a-plus for
me I know the Eagles have had a very
strange draft but this is a good athlete
a guy that could play special teams and
somebody that'll help them a lot right
away yep we are finally disagreeing
today I gave this one a c-minus I think
they reached when there were better
safeties on the board especially when
you're looking at someone you want to
play in the nickel thought there were
better players continues the theme that
I'm singing this draft of the Eagles
you're taking the right position maybe
but not the right player at the values
we'll see if Kol Wallace proves how to
write or me write or both of us run for
the Philadelphia Eagles
the Eagles have had a weird draft and
we're not just pokin because the left
goes not here this has been a weird
draft for them jaylen Rieger felt like a
reach
they take jaylen Hertz and they needed a
defensive back they really did cave on
Wallace here again not to not to pound
on Avon loss but in my opinion to reach
the bills are on the clock at 1:28 want
a shout out our guy Sam towles bills
mafia how many tables are we jumping
through after this tailgate or 21-8 do
we get to Buffalo with not a lot of
picks I think Brandon beam has done a
good job once again I can't wait to see
Zach Moss in that backfield I know
they're jacked about their draft so far
they've been patient
they've just let the value come to then
AJ epinet Zach Moss and I do think this
is I would not be surprised if they went
after a wide receiver here even after
trading for Stefon Diggs don't forget
that's who they picked with their
first-round pick was to find jigs
trading him from the Minnesota Vikings
so they've been smart and they've got
value to guys that also like there's a
theme here those are to the toughest
players at their position in the entire
draft class so Buffalo could go a lot of
different positions I think speed on
offense is gonna be a theme for them but
also as they continue to fill out that
secondary a little bit yeah
without a dad I think they could add at
corner you know we saw some interior
defensive linemen go but you know like
you said we're curious where FNS is
gonna play I think that's the question
right now they're a team that you know
with McDermott they're always gonna look
to load up on the secondary and we keep
hammering home how many good corners are
in this draft so I'm very curious here
guys I could see Bradley and I being a
bills kind of player especially if you
want to play epinet on the inside in
Connor they do go wide receiver and it's
Gabe Davis from UCF so not okay one of
the other wide receivers but a good
player
Gabe Davis from UCF we got to make a
video for Sam we got to do it the Gabe
Davis a player that I know we both liked
if it had not been for some injury
concerns so let's make a video
Gabe Davis going to the Buffalo Bills
Bill's mom mucus a big play wide
receiver Gabe Davis six to 216 Reina for
540 there's question about speed but
he's running away from those defenders
my comp for him Connor Quincey a noon
whoa and I had a third round great on
Gabe Davis so the Buffalo Bills third
pick in the draft they do this again
they get an exceptional value and
someone who now you have Stefon Diggs
you finally get a big receiver something
that was really missing from their
offensive weaponry how do you feel that
Gabe Davis going to the bills I feel
pretty good about it like you said they
needed a big target a guy that actually
did win down the field in college and
you also won across the middle of the
field and I think in the red zone that's
something the bills listen they're
pretty loaded at their top three wide
receiver spots but you still need depth
in the band they still need somebody for
those empty sets and when you look at
Gabe Davis I thought the hands were
pretty good super productive for UCF
once again there's a lot of good
receivers left on the board but he was
mixed in that group of six we have here
so I like it for the bills a very solid
pick this is a B on my end Matt yeah I
got a he was the number two receiver
left on my board
Donovan people show submission the only
one higher I like Gabe Davis especially
in this fit that Josh Allen needs big
targets extend that catch radius let's
make our man's job a little bit easier
the bills get a big white out in the
fourth round from South Carolina and
Gabe Davis all right bills off the board
and with excuse me UCF South Carolina
the Jets are on the clock again Connor
1:29 they got a quarterback in James
Morgan no defense it feels like it has
to be defense I know we said that last
time around but Brice hole you're gonna
see him at the top of our boards a lot
and I know folks probably wondering why
is Brice Hall falling in the draft and I
got a little note for you guys here
he was so team's before he got hurt this
year we're concerned about speed he had
a broken tibia and fibia according to a
source in mid-october so teams are very
very worried about how quickly he's
gonna get back on the field couldn't do
anything pre-draft even before things
were shut down because of Kovan 19 so
Brice Hall still on the board a good
player a well known player had he come
out last year's draft would have been
selected before now
the injury is pushing him down I think
the speed concerns on top of the injury
are a little bit more concerning for
teams yeah and you nailed it Matt you're
you know you're sitting here saying that
how much are you gonna get out of this
guy this year I think that's what teams
have concerns for and a lot of people
will sit there and say well we're this
late in the draft a lot of the players
you're seeing drafted today right now I
mean let's be honest they're gonna
contribute on special teams right away
and I know that you know some of the
pics we've even questioned like James
Morgan the Jets didn't have a backup
quarterback so all these teams right now
they're at least penciling these guys in
as special teams players or second
string players and unfortunately with
somebody like Bryce Hall who I'm very
very high on you might not get anything
from him for quite a bit yeah kind of
our presenting sponsor today we have to
thank you to these people rocket
mortgage and people across the country
are joining together to say thank you to
all the essential workers who leave
their homes every day so that we can
stay safe in ours share your thanks for
the folks on the front lines by posting
your thank-you video to everyone knows a
hero dot-com Semana all of us who've
been sitting on these desks throughout
the week are going to be doing after
this draft then again like left Koch up
saying that's 75 people behind the
scenes at least 75 people working behind
the scenes to make sure this thing goes
off without a hitch amazing producers
the tech people the camera folks
everyone running these amazing graphics
we have a ticker this year I think
that's pretty damn cool
so everyone behind the scenes here
bleach report thank you for all that
your hard work and we have your Jets on
the clock Connor 1:29 we'll see if they
go corner and they do not okay with a
pick is in the Jets at 129 Connor go
Cameron Clarke an offensive tackle so a
little bit of a beside athlete it
offensive tackle yeah you get Makai
backed in a camera Clark do not fight
the New York Jets offensive tackle know
my words of wisdom for you here early on
a Saturday morning don't fight the Jets
offensive tackles we will make a video
for our Jets friends in the app don't
forget you can leave your comments and
we'll check those out Charlotte
Cameron Clark right let's do a video
the New York Jets just want to punch it
in the mouth on the offensive line they
got Makai Becton now they get Cameron
Clark and offensive lineman from
Charlotte 6-4 308 pounds he could play
tackle Center I think he's a guard most
likely in the NFL put him on the
interior let him fight people in that
phone booth
he came all folks in the trenches even
had a smaller level of competition when
we did get to see him play up he looked
the part he really did mad this is
somebody that threw Clemson defenders
around so don't sleep on Cameron Clark
and I let's talk about the position fit
for the Jets you're sure he played
tackle that's the film you're gonna
watch this guy is going to be a guard at
the next level and once again you put it
next to Makai Becton that's a mean mean
nasty duo this guy is run blocking city
if he latches on to you guess what
you're going one direction and it's
right down into hell so this is a B for
the New York Jets they have a lot of
needs they need a lot of help but I
think cam Clark actually is one of the
best interior players on the board right
now and nobody's talking about him
because he played it Charlotte yeah they
should've been watching him and Alex
Highsmith in Charlotte he it's Abby from
me as well I like this spot for him so
much and I love what they're trying to
build on that offensive line Makai
Vechten now you get Cameron Clark the
Jets are gonna be a physical downhill
running team in 2020 oh right and pick
130 is in Connor this is the Minnesota
Vikings
and they're gonna take one of my
favorite players they drafted I love
Lynch a defensive lineman from Baylor
any time you watch Baylor 2019 who be
like who is that this is he looked like
JJ Watt on Baylor's defense that's the
type of role that he played so a huge
fan of James Lynch but it's really like
it's the hundred thirty is picking the
draft why are you two so excited about
this guy that's why we're here on day
three because we love players like James
Lynch we will make a video for this so
we'll give you our grades again
Minnesota Vikings get James Lynch play
on that defensive line Vikings are
quietly having a good draft year Conor
oh very good I look at James Lynch man I
had him 92nd overall so this is one of
the best players available today I'm
excited to talk about this guy
all right here we go the Minnesota
Vikings did James Lynch the big boy from
Baylor number 93 he was the rock of Matt
rules defense in Waco Texas
the Bears loved him Connor he could play
defensive end he could kick inside and
play tackle six for 289 he was my number
109 player in the draft I think the
value is very very good for where you
gain but also a little bit of a tone
Center for the Vikings I think he kicks
in we're gonna see him a three technique
early and often without it that you
can't run on this guy I love this pick
for the Vikings you watch James Lynch
play I thought he had you know a lot of
production as a pass rusher and as a run
defender I think he's one of those guys
that is a true three Tech and you see
the ability to break down and close and
tackle I mean really good balance for
his size which is impressive he was not
on the ground a lot once again a power
player he can drive the pocket backwards
I think for the Vikings here you're
getting a rotational run stopper with a
little bit of pass rush potential I
thought he was a third round player this
is late for him this is an A for Slick
Rick in the Vikings flickerings having a
good one a b-plus for me a player who
had thirteen and a half sacks in his
junior season opted to enter the NFL
Draft the Vikings get one of the better
defensive linemen in this year's class
in James Lynch out of Baylor and we're
gonna see Conner now a run on defensive
line of the Arizona Cardinals are up we
saw them go on with leaky flow to
earlier in the draft they still have
needs five technique they still need
help to free up Chandler Jones to free
up Isaiah Simmons and all the speed they
have on the back end
looking at the top available defensive
lineman excuse me I'm sorry the pick is
in looks like we're Chardon lawrence
from LSU is what I'm being told us to
pick our our guys and the producers can
confirm that but we're short Lawrence
and I'm gonna get excited about Rashard
Lawrence because he was one of my
sleepers in this draft where he didn't
get the recognition of the grant
dolphins Patrick Queen I agree Kayla
Vaughn chase on he opened the door for
all those players watch number 94 LSU
open the door for Kayla van chase on
playing for that five tech spot in that
30 man front so that you're getting a
good good player do not be surprised if
this man starts we're gonna make a video
because we're both so excited yeah
go from LSU when in doubt draft LSU
players this year that is the theme the
Arizona Cardinals continue to bolster
the defense they got Isaiah Simmons now
they get Rashard Lawrence the guy who
was opening all the plays up for caleb
on chase on off the edge six-foot to 308
pounds turn on his UCF highlights
tonight if you get a chance guys he
absolutely dominated and he did it
consistently in the SEC four tiers as a
starter I love the way he plays
penetrates he plays the run and again he
will lock out those offensive lineman so
that your edge rusher can get to the
quarterback cleanly I'm with you Matt
this is one of the most respected
players on that LSU defense hard-working
tough does the dirty work time and time
again sure he doesn't have your ideal
body type the NFL level he doesn't have
the combine numbers that everyone loves
but this guy is a football player and
you see what he's doing right here is
what he did a lot he took up blockers
and gave caleb on chase on the
opportunity to get one-on-ones as a pass
rusher so this is somebody that comes in
is a good run defender does the dirty
work really just brings us you know
lunch pail every day I love saying that
paint school saying this guy is an
a-minus pick here he will play right
away you are right and he will help the
interior of that runs offense yeah I
like what the Cardinals are doing it's
scary as a Niners fan to see this but an
a for me the value that fit the
personality what you're getting in terms
of effort like Connor said and
leadership and awesome pick for the
Cardinals in fourth in the fourth round
all right TV has seen that we're going
fast they're trying to catch us Connor
we're gonna stay at 132 the Minnesota
Vikings take Troy die linebacker from
Oregon one of the most productive
linebackers in college football over the
last couple of years
put a little bit undersized so we are
gonna break this one - you can see our
grades in the video but Troy died we got
a chance to see him excuse me a lot you
got to see him this year I believe
but Troy died tall linebacker good
instincts again we'll give our grades
reward here we're flying so fast I'm
like who's the good players left right
now right kind of a polarizing prospect
though when you talked to team some
people liked him some really thought
that he was a developmental guy so we'll
do a video here Troy died going to the
Minnesota Vikings the Minnesota Vikings
continued to bolster that defense troy
died oregon and a solid all-around
linebacker one of those guys you write
your notes just a football player looks
the part great length 6-foot 3 to 31
pounds you're gonna love this Connor
might count for him was tell v'n Smith
playing a weak side linebacker use that
athleticism use the link number 117 on
my board but actually at 70 overall
grade which puts him closer to round 3
where we saw a cluster of players right
there I like Troy died best linebacker
available on my board at this point um
with you all the way Miller I had him in
round three and he is my best linebacker
available you watch Detroit I play I
love that's Helton Smith comp weak side
backer run and chase backer good and
coverage really really tough play to
hurt this year somebody that really
could do it all for Oregon kind of felt
like he was the heart and soul of that
defense and they asked him to line up at
every single linebackers spot it but at
the next level I think he's gonna be a
cover backer he can blitz very well at
this point of the draft when you're
getting starting players which the
Vikings just do year after year after
year and they're doing it multiple times
this year this is an a for me I like
Troy died and I think he's gonna have
time now to get healthy with this long
extended stretch off and he's gonna get
right yeah the guy played eight games
with a cast on his hand in 2019 so you
know you're getting toughness this is a
for me this Vikings draft I think behind
the time we
back the end of day three and look at it
wery very very impressed what they
continue to do on defense especially I
don't have the Vikings continue to just
good players just fall right into their
laps I mean you get James Lynch now you
get Troy dye and the Seahawks pick is in
it is Colby Parkinson the tight in from
Stanford so you normally think a
Stanford tight end it's gonna be a big
slow guy who can't can't get down the
field he just blocks that is not true
Colby Parkinson is an athlete so we are
gonna make a video for this one the
Seattle Seahawks Connor if you are ready
we are ready we're gonna break down
Colby Parkinson going to the Seattle
Seahawks
sure
the Seattle Seahawks give Russell Wilson
another big target in Colby Parkinson
the six foot seven 252 pound tight in
height link speed you see he's just
running away from folks four seven seven
at six seven it's hard to do
that's what Colby Parkinson did Mike hop
Labine toy low low another stanford
player so that's a little bit rich but I
love what he can do working in the seam
the Seahawks now have a collection of
tight ends that is very very impressive
so it will dis Lee comes back from
injury next year Connor your thoughts on
Colby Parkinson he was 155 on my board
they get him here I believe 131 yes I
had him in the fifth round Matt so and
that's a fifth-round grade not a
projection so I think this isn't really
shocking for him in this spot right now
you talk about the size former five-star
recruit expectations we're way bigger
I'd like to see him get more work as you
see there as a shielding seemed target
you're seeing all these seam targets
right here catch and run kind of player
he's gonna be bigger than anybody that
covers him you just want to see him play
like that but when you look at this pick
overall I like minor Bryant better in
this spot and maybe Brice and Hopkins
but it's not a bad selection because I
think the projection makes sense this is
a b-minus year for Seattle getting some
tight end help I promise we don't see
each other's grades before this I've
given it a beat as well a team captain
someone who's big rust just throw it up
over the top
let our man go up win over the top Colby
Parkinson goes from Stanford up the
coast to the Seattle Seahawks you know
there's the there's the the drinking
game that our sticky of the Year Andrew
Magnuson made day three should have been
how many times do we agree on a grade
and I promise we don't know each other
it's great before the video I'm usually
you can see me like swiping it on the
tablet as Connors talking so it's just I
think when you talk to each other about
players for a year your grades gonna be
pretty similar yeah it happens I mean
and we also talked about this guy you
know on stick to football a decent bit I
think we were kind of ready for him to
be one of these day three tight ends
Seattle is one of those teams math that
they will look at a player that either
has a crazy athletic profile but didn't
have a ton of production or had a
five-star profile coming out of high
school and they're gonna say hey we're
gonna coach them up and get more out of
him than you did in college Stanford I
think has done good with tight ends some
wondering how much meat is left on the
table for Parkinson to grow but I think
we like the player and once again it's
late in the draft take the risk yeah
kind of the Atlanta Falcons have made a
questionable pick I'm Kirsty if you had
this guy in your top 200 why should I
pick 134 overall they take jaylen
Hawkins a safety from Cal he was a
combine invite we got to see him there
he was my number 25 safety in the class
the Atlanta Falcons take jaylen Hawkins
from Cal yeah he didn't make my top 200
Matt and I have a lot of safeties left
on this list and I did more than 200
players he did not make the cut so I'm
very surprised that seems very very
early for him it kind of reminds me of
our Jacksonville Quincy Williams pick
from last year were both sitting there
looking at each other going ok right I
had a scout text me he said Jalen
Hawkins question mark I said yeah I
didn't like him he said yeah none of us
did either that's the question mark he
wasn't on the board for this team either
so the Falcons may be reaching
definitely reaching according to our
board denied him at 298 overall a great
of 55 which on my board means you're
like a backup hopefully you can make a
roster here's the big board of best
available for both of us you see mine
Bryce Hall down for people's Jones
Connor and Mike Robinson and I know they
meet Robinson Robertson excuse me you
have him graded that's a projection of
how good you think he's gonna be in the
NFL not a prediction of where he's gonna
be drafted just so folks aren't like why
is this you know test if the players
still on the board we knew he was gonna
go round four or later because of size
limitations but a meek Robertson one of
the feistiest players in the entire
draft class one of the best press
coverage corners in the draft so sue me
fun to see where he lands today yeah and
I think that's a great point you make
Matt you know you look at a lot of the
grades here a lot of the players being
taken by carry fit their sixth round
grades but there's only so many of those
top grades in the draft so because the
guys taking in the fourth round with the
sixth round grade the potential the fit
might stack up and that's how you get
the higher grades so our grading system
it does seem team friendly at times but
I mean there hasn't been as many reaches
as we're actually accustomed to year
after year let's talk about the Steelers
right now yeah they are on the clock
pick 135 again chase Claypool Alex
Highsmith
visits him they believe they have a
super one do they also got Anthony
mcFarland earlier
so I ad running back would be a little
bit of a gadget player and they were
going to go with a mean physical mauler
Kevin Dotson the offensive guard in
Louisiana he was the biggest riser for
us as we do our draft 400 series you
guys are getting those alerts in the app
of the scouting reports that we put out
myself Jared brown and Melo
Kevin Dawson was the player where we had
to go back and reevaluate the grid
because he was low because injury but
when you watched him play Connor it was
like this guy should be a second or
third round pick if it wasn't for injury
the biggest question is a small school
guy so you didn't always get to see him
playing against a great level of
competition but I am I was a big heavy
Dodson fan 135 overall on my board six
for 310 his grade a perfect 69 overall
yeah I'm with you there Matt as I look
him up on my board I know he was at the
top my interior so I had him 155 I
forget what you said but I think I look
at him as an interior player that you
know you know I'll tell you how you find
him you watch rubber hunt and you go who
is this other guy that could play as
well yeah that was they like yet you're
watching Robert hunt you who's this
other guard who's really really good so
a big Kevin Dotson fan we are here at
bleacher report again check out those
scouting reports that are coming out in
the app if you're watching this on
YouTube make sure you have the app so
that you can get those top 400 scouting
reports it's on 2255 picks you have 400
scattering reports hell of a bargain
alright who is on the clock now the
Steelers went at 135
Kevin Dodson the Rams are on the clock
at 136 and every time I see this on the
run down if who's on the board it's
logos and I have to let look three times
like who is who this team the Rams new
logo I'm never gonna get used to it
they're always gonna have Saint Louis
Rams and I'm never gonna get the logo
I've done the same thing and I know
we're not doing the video but I do want
to say Mike Kevin Dotson grade was a B+
I wrote it down because I've officially
reached the point mat of autopilot where
you say the pic I processed the player
for three seconds I like it is ranking
and then make the grade is just an
assembly line it's like Chipotle you go
they ask you you want it to go you want
it to stay you get your rice chicken and
get the hell out and then I come in an
order quesadilla mess everybody's dip
yeah I want to throw you under the bus
like that I do it don't care now yeah I
do the curbside I'm getting quesadilla
there's no line so this the next two
weeks on stick to football we're gonna
break down every division so one show
Monday I am C East Wednesday AFC North
we are going to go division by division
breaking the draft down myself Connor
and mellow make sure you check that out
wherever you get your podcast Spotify
stitcher Apple podcast but most
importantly you can watch us just like
you're doing right now in the bleacher
report at five p.m. Eastern Monday
Wednesday Thursday so check those out
we're gonna go deep dive on the drafts
that we've seen from each division the
Rams on the clock at 136 overall
Chipotle will be I want a hectare of
this show guaranteed the comment section
is just trashing the logo which is fair
I just think it's so funny they're
literally like what the hell logo is
that it is so good it's the best
comb-over maybe ever
just the blonde comb-over on the LA
absolutely love it absolutely love it
the Rams are gonna make a pick we'll
stop making fun of their logo there it
is again never mind we're gonna keep my
cam akers good all right back Vaughn
Jefferson it is a good draft some injury
questions oh man Jefferson some injury
crashes with the foot throw Lewis some
injury questions with the knee but I
like all of these players I think this
is one of those the end of the draft if
you're like hey Miller they took for
your top 100 players like hey I know
he's a good draft but there are some
injury questions with at least two of
those players yeah there is I think that
Terrell Lewis ones the big one and we
talked about it kind of been a somber
attitude you talked about a first-round
pass rush talent that we're convinced we
don't know if he'll make it through a
season at this point now when he's on
the field he is very very impressive and
it goes back to something Matt a lot of
players that come out of Alabama they
are really really banged up so that was
an interesting draft we love cam Akers
we felt van Jefferson was a little bit
early I thought throughout Burgess might
actually be the best pick there in terms
of value and what they needed yeah I
reached out to some scouts asked about
Jake from so why is Jake from stone the
board none of us can figure it out here
bleacher report what our teams say about
Jake from kind of no one knows normally
you get like a smartass response back of
like oh he thinks response that's
usually what you get but Saturday
morning I think everyone's feeling nice
so Jake from doesn't come off the board
here but a tight end does Bryson hop
kans tied into the LA Rams at 1:36
overall he is a lot like their other two
Titans this is just this girl over again
yeah it's the same player we'll do a
video for the Rams since we just made
fun of their video for an hour but I
like Bryce and Hopkins we'll get into it
with our grades and with a breakdown of
Bryce and Hopkins it tied in for the
Rams let's do this Connor
the LA Rams are going to try to outscore
everybody they add van Jefferson Camp
acres now they get one of the most
athletic Titans in the 2020 class Bryson
Hopkins from Purdue my comp for him was
Evan Engram put this man in the slot let
him run up the seam with that 466 speed
Conner
that's all impressive you might be
wondering why is he still on the board
drops were a big issue for him and he's
never blocked anyone in his life not
even on Twitter
nah it's true you know honestly when you
say that it kind of makes you think that
he's a poor man's Eric Ebron the drops
are a big concern he's not blocking
anybody but I thought he was a good
athlete on the field Matt people are
gonna search the combine numbers and be
a little underwhelmed I thought his play
speed was pretty pretty good I value
them at 149 so this is exactly pretty
much where I had the player he fits
their offense they want a little bit of
explosiveness they want to move tight
end they're not gonna ask the guy to
come in and be an inline player they're
not gonna ask the guy to come in and be
tight in number two he's gonna be a
third tight end set you can actually see
him in the backfield and get rolled out
a little bit as well so for the Rams on
this pick there's actually a great
scheme fit for the player as I drop my
grade this is a b-plus which is a much
better grade than their logo gets I wish
I were an artist I would have put the
wave over a b-plus for me as well I like
Bryson Hopkins a player who I was much
higher on early in the process
my fellow Scouts or bleacher report
talked me down moving him down but still
a great value where the Rams game here
at pick 136 overall Bryson Hopkins goes
from Purdue to the LA Rams all right man
the Rams the Rams about a good draft
like we said there's some injury
questions in there you got to worry
about that we have the Jags coming up at
137 overall that a great first round CJ
Henderson Kate LaVon chase on the Chiefs
are up after that pick 138 then the
Raiders 139 the Jags are back on the
clock at 140 so the Jags two picks here
in the next four and you you don't want
to skip the Jags obviously this
important team will talk about two picks
the Chiefs of Raiders it seems like
they're just going like pound for pound
like punch for punch the Raiders had
Henry rugs the Chiefs and Clyde Edwards
a layer there's a race in the AFC West
to see who can score more points right
now the Broncos have added a ton of
weapons as well hey Jerry Judy they get
Albert
Oh from the zoo not gonna try to say
that name again I got lucky once you did
pretty good it's just time thank you
right it's gonna be a shootout in the
West this year yeah I think so I think
when you look at all those teams they're
loading up on athletic offensive linemen
they're loading up on weapons they feel
pretty good about their quarterbacks I'm
excited to watch the West when you look
and I talking about both West not just
even the AFC not just the NFC you look
at those teams there's a lot of athletic
quarterbacks between those divisions and
it just seems like they sat there and
said hey if you're a wide receiver we're
drafting you yep and the pick is in for
the Jags they go misses Michigan State
excuse me Michigan State Corner Josiah
Scott a good slot corner the Athletics
it's gonna be intriguing two teams and
this is a need for them even after
drafting CJ Henderson earlier in this
class Connor but Jo's ask Scott I saw a
lot of buzz for him in the lead-up to
this draft I had him at 167 overall comp
2ej Gaines he's five nine 185 we are not
gonna do a video for this when we're
getting ready for the Chiefs and Raider
so you we can give you the grade right
here live a 4-4-2 and the 40 though is
intriguing in round four I think this is
a little bit of a reach here on Josiah
Scott but I like the position for them
at least yeah so he didn't make my
initial top 200 I went back and watch
cuz of course you got some flack I
thought very very undersized very very
sticky the problem is even if you are
sticky you will get bodied I like that
at the next level I think he could play
mad I think he could be a backup slot
corner I think if I revised that I could
have found a place for him in the corner
rankings but overall you know I think
this is a little early for him I thought
he was gonna go more in the sixth round
of this draft yep Josiah Scott goes to
the Jaguars
here's the message from our presenting
sponsor the amazing people at rocket
mortgage by Quicken Loans
[Music]
big special shout-out to all the
essential workers out there I want to
say thank you to my sister joy thank you
thank you thank you sir
don't forget after the draft go -
everyone knows a hero calm leave your
video thanking essential workers
something we can all find time to do
here on draft weekend Connor we know the
Jags pick the Chiefs are on the clock at
138 and we've seen yeah where do you
think they go eat mr. Chiefs yeah it's
my my son's team and when I asked him
this morning we FaceTime said where the
Chiefs do today
he does not care by day three they draft
you 86 years old we'll get him there
they've gone running back they've got
with an athletic linebacker in Willie
gay next year he'll probably on the desk
with us but then they go offensive
tackle Lukas Nang if I had my pick
moving my top available player Brice
Hall they need a corner I like Turkey
and request
I like the day Bob batt brought back for
Shaw Breeland those two corners are not
good enough to compete with what we were
just talked about in the AFC West and
there you go Bret Beach thank you for
watching our stream the Chiefs have
drafted Bryce Hall corner from Virginia
T I know we have a huge Chiefs following
on our stick to football podcast we
appreciate you guys as soon as we can I
will definitely be back there tailgating
a lot Jay talking about Brice Hall a
steal here in the draft they pick 138
absolutely this is a phenomenal pick I
hope we get to make a video for this
pick we're doing it buddy you win a
Super Bowl we do videos about your team
that's the that's a bear you get a cool
trophy fair you get a killer parade and
we do videos and if you don't win a
Super Bowl since the 60s we still do
videos about your team because I care
about the dreads I thought you're
talking with the Browns so we do them to
do videos for them - all right let's do
this
the Kansas City Chiefs needed a quarter
and they get one of the best in this
class with exceptional technique down
the field physical the biggest question
speed and injury but six 122 pounds item
at sixty six overall Connor Jay Rogers
my comp was Josh Norman we know Steve
Spagnola wants that physicality need
guys who were big to run down the field
their corner Croft is very thin in
Kansas City
his charcandrick west and a lot of guys
a one-year deals like Rashad Breeland
this is an exceptional value and then
also this is a very good scheme fit
without a doubt man I mean you look at
Bryce Hall here I thought he was a top
80 player in this trap and he wasn't
hurt he was a lock to be a top 50 pick
you talk about an outside corner that
can press that can run down the field
with you and makes a play on the
football he let the FBS in 2018 and
passes broken up and you see it here the
ability to come down he'll come over the
top break up the pass he finds the
football very well a good tackler just
an all-around tough player at this point
of the draft it's a home run even if you
draft them and stash them for all 2020
so give them that Super Bowl ring if you
win one why he's sitting from the
sidelines in come in and be a starter
one day just needs to get healthy it's
an a-plus-plus for price on the Chiefs
there you go the Kansas City champion
Chiefs do it again a plus big for Brett
beech and Andy Reed I'm so glad you said
that because that's what I was gonna say
Connor this got my knife to play this
year and that's great for the Chiefs who
can stash him maybe you get him back for
the stretch run in the playoffs with
Brice Hall he will be your starting
corner in 2021 Chiefs fans guaranteed
all right Chiefs fans have to feel great
the Raiders are on the clock counter at
139 this is the first of the round four
comp picks we're almost through around
four we're gonna be here with you today
until the end of round 5 don't freak
never mind never mind we're changing
this the guy who tipped the pick was
wrong so we got it wrong in our group
chat here I apologize Chiefs fans we
were so excited Oh knock Brice Hall hey
this happens the guy who tipped the pic
apparently was joking so someone
hilarious that should be the punishment
that was terrible
okay so they still get a good player
Twitter
I want to apologize the Chiefs fans
because sometimes this happens in the
world of fast-paced journalism but they
still go with a defensive back in the
the knock on hole was he's not very fast
instead they got one of the most
athletic defense defensive backs in the
class ladarius need from Louisiana Tech
so not your guy and meek Robertson his
teammate ladarius Snead so man you hate
when people do that to you but what it
happens so we're gonna do another video
that's what would have happened if the
Chiefs had ready to rock all this is
what does happen when they take ladarius
Snead from Louisiana Tech the Kansas
City Chiefs we know they need help in
the secondary and boy do they get it
with an athlete and ladarius need out of
Louisiana Tech six-foot 192 four three
seven speed you got to stop Henry drugs
and Jerry Judy in your own division now
this is the type of speed that goes and
gets it done Connor I don't know that
he's a starter right away but he is at
least gonna be a contributor in nickle
and you're hoping in 2021 this guy can
break into the lineup yeah and I think
with that speed mat he's gonna be on
kick coverage units as a gunner so I
think when you look at ladarius Snead
this is somebody you hope you can
develop maybe as a free safety somebody
that you might ask to handle some
coverage responsibilities even at a
corner spot a nickel spot where tight
ends I like the speed I like the
athleticism I think the instincts are
definitely a step behind here and that's
why he's being drafted this late in the
draft but you're getting an athlete that
I think can play special teams right
away as well so I look at ladarius Snead
it's kind of right where I had them
right now
b-minus for the Kansas City Chiefs as
they add to a much-needed unit they're
secondary now I want a - Lieutenant City
Chiefs I love the athleticism and again
not in the top corner or safety on the
board for me but when you look at the
rest of the NFC West now it isn't track
meet it's a four by 100 that we're gonna
see in the West and Snead definitely
brings that speed to compete with now
rugs Judy on his own team you got Tiger
Hill so the Chiefs get an athlete in the
fourth round
all right so Louisiana Tech this is your
a moment guys Amica Robertson comes off
the board right after this at 139 so the
Raiders get a meek Robertson after the
Chiefs get ladarius Sneed and whoever
tipped the pick wrong let's just all
agree we're blocking that person on
Twitter just got to do it can't be a
jerk I'm not great was it like a
verified account I don't know I don't
know what's happening we're moving on
look live and let learn or live and
learn a meet Robertson Connor you're I
believe one of your top available
players if not beat is the board V but
is the writer so we're doing a video
because we love the Raiders a meet
Robertson Louisiana Tech let's do this
thing
Vegas Raiders get one of the toughest
feistiest fastest meanest corners in the
class in a meek Robertson no he's not
big a 5/8 187 he plays like he's 6 foot
210 he was in the grill of every
receiver Louisiana Tech face no matter
how big no matter how fast the meek
Robertson is a perfect slot quarter
Connor I know you were even higher on
him than I was yeah I think he's the
best slot corner in the draft Matt and
he carried a second-round grade for me
so he was my best available player on
the board and this is what the Raiders
do they get bused to fights the really
tough players especially on the back end
of their defense he comes down he
tackles he wants the football when it's
in the air he finds the football with
soft hands so I looked I think the
closing speed was very very good I
thought he was insanely insanely sticky
in coverage he had multiple games with
multiple turnovers I love this pic at
this point of the draft this guy should
come in and fight to start at the slot
cornerback spot right away I don't know
why he's on the board but the NFL does
this every year where they forget that
this is a really really good player with
great on ball production this is an
a-plus as the Raiders continue to crush
the later rounds of this draft I didn't
know the Raiders can trap players not
from Clemson they get an 8 just for that
from me like hop Quan Dre dig so he
could play corner play safety big huge
fans of Meek Robinson who once he gets
healthy ain't we see him on the field
for the Raiders in 2020
so a little Louisiana Tech love the
Jarius need goes then Amica Robertson
Connor the pick after that the
Jacksonville Jaguars take should kill
quarter man linebacker from the you so
stay in-state
get themself a linebacker they picked up
Joe Schobert and free agency but they're
still had a need at linebacker even with
models Gary in there so they get Shack
quarterman I will be underside around
seven great on him thought he struggled
and yeah he's a bit of a throat attacker
yeah so he was 219 on my board so we are
not doing a video because of the fact
that round seven player who gets drafted
around for we're gonna talk about it
right here it would have to make a great
video so Shaq quarterman one of the
better I think
run defending linebackers but it's 2020
everyone throws the ball 40 times a game
now yeah that's the problem with him mad
I think when quarterman got to Miami
there were expectations for him to be
the next great linebacker at the U and
he was an average player I think he had
some really really good games I think he
was a four-year starter and when you
watch him play the speed is lacking I
think he hits very very hard the
downhill closing speed was okay but the
lateral speed does not exist he cannot
run with running backs and tight ends
and like you said I had a seventh round
great on him I have Evan Weaver and Joe
Bochy ahead of him right now so it's a
bruiser I think you can find bruisers
honestly in the UDF a process man I'm
gonna be honest here I'm a little
surprised that he got drafted before
around 6 yeah I was too looking at my
board of who we have available a lot a
lot better players so the Jags take
check quarterman john reed the corner
from penn state goes to the houston
texans we are going to make a video
about this one because we love Dover and
actually we love to shop on so a video
for John Reed going to the Houston
Texans Cana get your grade ready
though Houston Texans are putting a
playmaker in the secondary with John
Reid look at that b-roll lining up with
my words John Reid is a playmaker Connor
449 probably gonna play on the inside of
510 187 had a good combine process 20
bench reps good all-around athlete at
Penn State they put him on an island a
lot
we saw him often in zone coverage the
heat fits in very very well to Stevens
and fills a need a little bit of a reach
for me I had him at 177 on the board
yeah a small corner mat here a guy
that's a pretty good athlete and when
you come out of Penn State they often
often are now I think you look at the
interception numbers they're you know
pretty decent like you said playmaker
explosive I think short area quickness
is very very good I think the questions
are arm length number one he really
can't survive on the outside that much
we know I saw him get beat a lot
honestly in the Big Ten Matt I think
there's a little early for me there are
better corners on the board but if you
needed a slot guy this was one of the
better ones available so on the fence
don't exactly love this player in this
spot it's gonna be a see from me for
John Reed yep and I wouldn't see as well
I think a little bit of a reach I like
the position need I like the athleticism
you're drafting a nickel corner here in
the fourth round that's not bad by you
see so good pick guys good pick for
Houston Texas John Reed goes from Penn
State where Bill O'Brien used to be the
head coach now he joins him in Houston I
don't you can see when the synapses fire
in my brain I'm like oh he recruited
that guy oh yeah that's what happened
right right the rich with that right the
Washington Redskins that pick 140 to get
a big long wide receiver Antonio Gandy
golden from Liberty small school player
who we saw at the Senior Bowl of course
we're gonna make a video because Connor
loves this guy he was my top player on
the board other than Donovan people's
Jones so I guess that would make him my
second receiver on the board sound
numbers work so we're gonna break this
down it's been a long week guys I stayed
up way too late playing n-c-double-a 14
last night - no I imagine sleeping
right right the Washington Redskins go
and get a big target down the field and
Ted Antonio dandy golden from Liberty
6-4 to 23 the catch radius is there the
strong hands are there we saw him at the
2020 Reese's Senior Bowl against power
five corners there was no drop-off in
play I think there's some questions
about speed with that four six time but
if you put him down in the field just
let him out jump people Connor
he was number 105 of my board with the
greatest 73 yeah Matt I had him as a
fourth round player a fourth round grade
so I actually projected him to go late
third round and when you look at Gandy
golden he's not that much different from
what they have in Kelvin Harmon and I
mean that in a good way I think he's a
very good possession player I don't
think you see a lot of lateral movement
I see good hops good at the catch point
strong hands
incredible blocker this guy rings it on
the outside as a blocker pretty good
tracking ability as well he's one of the
best receivers on the board the only guy
I had ahead of him was Donovan peoples
Jones in Isaiah Hodgins so this is an
a-minus for me I like that the Redskins
are looking for wide receiver helped on
day three of this draft right now yeah
this is where you get receivers this
where you take a chance on a guy who was
a small school player bass trades an
a-plus for me I think he's gonna fit
very well with what Dewayne Haskins once
big receiver worked that sideline route
again 105 on the board you get him here
this is an exceptional value for
Washington in the fourth round
the Redskins may have won it's an
underrated receiving corps and you add
an antonio gibson so just keep taking
people with the name antonio it's
working for them but scary Terry Antonio
Gibson big Andy golden in there this
this wide receiver group starting to
look pretty dangerous yeah at least they
have some players that could be good
possession guys for Dwane Haskins we
know scary Terry can went over the top I
think when you look at somebody like
Antonio Gibson he's a big play threat
and now you have two possession players
Calvin Harmon is penciled in to start
for them and Gandy golden as well so
they're getting value at this spot and I
think once again they need to load up on
the skill talent for their young
quarterback I would like to say thank
you to the Twitter user who told me to
turn the lock screen on on the iPad so
it doesn't rotate glaziers out thank you
I don't know why didn't think of that
three days ago appreciate you don't
great you can leave comments in the app
when we have time when we get a head of
TV we're gonna read those comments show
you guys the Baltimore Ravens are on the
clock at 143 overall Preston Abbott
wants to know why no love for deep a dpj
done with people's Jones from Michigan
Conner hmm well I think
did he ask why he's still on the board
why no love yeah why is he still there
yeah so I have a third round great on
him but he is all athlete and no
production right now now I do think Shay
Patterson held him back but I think when
you look at Donovan peoples Jones the
routes are not super super clean I think
people do wonder can he separate
consistently he's a phenomenal athlete
he'll beat you at the catch point I
think will be a more productive player
at the next level with a better
quarterback in a past friendly offense
so I like him at I had him in the third
round I actually thought he would go
right in the third round this is a bit
of a slide for such a polarizing highly
touted recruit at one time Connor I
picked 143 overall the Baltimore Ravens
select someone from Michigan not Donovan
people's Jonah they go offensive guard
Ben Bredesen I was exactly as we talked
about like right like some players look
like they belong with certain teams we
talked about that a lot night one Ben
Branson looks like he belongs with the
Baltimore Ravens and they need to get
younger on the interior offensive line
this pick makes a ton of sense what they
do up front the way they run the ball we
get to do a video because we love the
Ravens draft class
the Baltimore Ravens continue to bolster
the offensive line been bredesen from
Michigan you looking at blocking out
with power 6 5 315 number 131 overall my
board with a very nice grade of 69
overall Connor what did this pick came
in we both said god this guy is a raven
he belongs in Baltimore and the Ravens
get another mean run blocker upfront
yeah I had him a little earlier than
this man I believe I had him right at
1:15 so when you look at Ben bredesen I
think he's strong really powerful run
blocker I think he's got very heavy
hands he's somebody in pass protection
that he might not have the quickest feet
and you could see him duck his head at
times but I think he has all the anchor
strength in the world and that's what
the Ravens really prioritize so this was
a player that I thought would go at the
top of the fourth round instead he
waited a little longer to hear his name
called I think he could thrive in a gap
rushing attack at the next level and I
think for Baltimore to add more to the
interior offensive line when the value
seized but this one the Ravens master at
they get players that should have went
30 picks earlier all the time this isn't
a - for me I think he's a very solid
backup from day one love it were
together a pick for me he's at least a
backup might be a starter in 2021 as
they turnover that offensive line sub in
Branson goes from Michigan to Baltimore
where the scheme fit and the value are
perfect what John Harbaugh is doing
there with the Ravens flock
I like that pic right we're gonna keep
going here flying here round yet now
we're almost in the fifth round the cop
picks here pick 144 count in the Seattle
Seahawks they take a running back DJ
Dallas from do you think that's healthy
in context this year I like DJ Dallas
like him a lot we're gonna do a video
we're gonna break it down because the
you we talked to Clint Porter's about
him week zero out in Vegas doing our
show at Caesar's Palace we're talking
about deejay Dallas we're gonna break
down the video here though instead of
talking about it with you guys let's do
a little video Connor the Seattle
Seahawks love depth at the running back
position and they get a baller here DJ
Dallas from the u5 10 to 17 was the man
there until dislocated elbow caused him
to miss the bowl game 5 10 to 17 funny
enough our draft 400 player comparison
Chris Carson for the house I see a ttle
so the scheme is beautiful I was gonna
say if you wanted a backup for Chris
Carson this is kind of Chris Carson
where's the power runner a North and
South kind of runner a really hard nosed
guy I like DJ Dallas it was you know
Benjamin and then him on my board now
they're very different players so when
you look at Dallas a North and South
kind of guy who lowered that shoulder
will keep the feet chugging along their
Seattle that's what they look for Adam
as the 130 5th player in this draft and
they get him a little later than that so
I really really like this pick for the
Seahawks it's a perfect scheme fit for
them it makes complete sense he's
somebody that can spell Carson we know
running back to get her all the time DJ
Dallas actually might be a sneaky impact
rookie at some point in the year this is
an a for me for those Seahawks yeah I
gave it a B I like DJ Dallas I had a
couple of other running backs higher
than him on the board though I think the
key is wood who do we get did we get the
guy we saw early in his career where the
ball skills were there but he's not
gonna have to be the man in Seattle they
add another piece to the rotation in the
backfield so Abbey for me deejay Dallas
goes to the Seattle Seahawks all right
Connor two more picks in this round they
both belong to the Philadelphia Eagles
so the Eagles are close on this thing
out strong in this draft hopefully left
go somewhere enjoying what they're doing
not freaking out like he did when Jalen
Rhaegar was the pic were you surprised
that he didn't lose it on Jalen hurts
not on Jalen hurts but on that pic uh I
think he that point he was battered
where he didn't want to crush the player
I also think Jalen hurts is like very
very likable player it was more
confusing than anger but yes it was a
he's a curious earlier that's the way I
would describe the Eagles draft in Matt
this is something where we can nerd out
for a moment is there any part of you
that wonders when you lose Joe Douglas
and Andrew berry in the same seat in the
same year span how that right packs your
scouting Department absolutely I mean
we've seen that in the past like when
Green Bay loses a bunch of guys how it
affects them it usually doesn't affect
you that year it's usually the next year
because you still have all that
information for the current year so I
think that will be telling does
Philadelphia now that it's just how a
Roseman for the most part losing his two
best scouts is two lieutenants how much
that affects their decision-making you
would have to think that also Doug
Peterson's very involved with what
they're doing let's take a look at the
BP a here done with people's Jones for
me Stanford Samuels Jake Fromm Soph
they're Bradley and I Alton Robinson
yours we got a couple similar but Kenny
Wilkinson Hunter Bryant different for
you still on the board yeah I think when
you look at it with Kenny I expected him
to be you know much lower on team boards
than my board I just see him as a high
floor player he's gonna bring it as a
situational pass rusher hunter Brian is
him move tight end a pass catching tight
end so those guys are role players but
at this point at the draft they're
really good at their roles so I like
them in those spots and as you see a lot
of overlap with me and Matt we both
value Bradley and I as a productive edge
rusher we both think Jake Fromm could be
that long-term backup spot starter kind
of player and then Donovan people's
Jones who we have really only nine spots
apart you look at him he's just an
athlete playing receiver and you hope a
team can figure out how to develop him
into more of that red zone dynamic
threat he could be their counter pick
145 the Eagles pick is in it is Jack
Driscoll the offensive tackle from
Auburn so they go offensive
it feels like they are just picking
things they don't need yet you notice I
no longer it offensive tackle I don't
get it you have Lane Johnson you took
Andre Dillard in the first last year and
there are still good players on the
board who could be contributors this
whole draft leading up to it for months
we've said this is a deep draft class I
know one team had 32 actual first-round
grades that never happens
there stands in the fourth round I 20
and I'm like oh a jerk when I grade and
I had 20 I had 25 that was I think three
more five more than I've ever had it's
crazy how good this draft is right so
normally I have like 15 but here is the
pick I believe being told let's check
here nope okay I don't trust that guy
nevermind thought I had it but no we're
not going we're not doing that again
not doing it glad I didn't say his name
on at pick 146 we'll see the Eagles -
Jack Driscoll with that first one Jack
Driscoll right tackle ID around seven
great on him he's just not athletic
enough to play in the NFL and it felt
like the Eagles I know they like big
guys in the middle but you got to be
able to move a little bit and know you
can do that
yeah no fee for Jack Driscoll didn't
make my top 200 there are good players
on the board on offensive line right now
here Matt I'd like some of the players
that are left so when you look at and
not a ton but I just he wasn't somebody
that I considered a top 200 player I
don't think he could survive at tackle
the next level I don't see any upside of
guard yep yep 215 on my board yeah that
have been a D for me but yeah yeah
likewise a lot of good players left as
we get ready to start round five don't
forget Connor I will be here with you
until the end of round five you can
catch our breakdown of the entire draft
over the next two weeks on stick to
football whether you want the podcast
version you get that wherever you get
your show or watch it right here in the
BR app on Tuesday for Wednesday no
Monday stay Thursday still long week
guys right here's the best players
available as we get ready to transition
to round five we've talked a lot about
Donovan peoples Jones Jake Fromm is
still on the board that might be I
wonder if we see someone trying to come
up to get Jake from Philadelphia is on
the clock you would think they're done
drafting backup quarterbacks
you have to wonder if somebody movie out
for Jake from they're done with that I
think when you look at from it it's this
tells me Matt everything we needed to
know
we were wondering will teams value from
brain enough to take him in the top
three rounds the physical ability does
not exist I'm sorry and there's plenty
of guys that have succeeded at the next
level at the quarterback position off of
being the smartest person on the field
and having a mediocre at best arm I
think that's from but those guys are
outliers they just don't exist very
often and I think when you're using a
pick on a guy like that you don't want
it to be in the top four rounds like
come for Jake for almost Kurt cousins
and that's a ceiling comp not who he
walks in as yeah and so that's it that's
the type you're not getting a great arm
you're hoping that his IQ I know
everyone talks about Oh his accuracy so
good I actually never thought his
accuracy was that good you see the
Eagles are on the clock here this is
excuse me is the last five picks john
reed penn state to houston Ateneo Gandy
golden from Liberty to Washington Ben
Brennan from Michigan DJ Dallas from the
UN Jack Driscoll the offensive tackle
from Auburn goes to Philadelphia the
Eagles pick ease and I believe that 146
we should have that shortly to close out
round four Adam Schefter is on ESPN
right now Connor talking about how the
Bears have not made an announcement on
Mitchell Travis Keys fifth year option
and people around the league believe
they will not the fact though they have
announced that now is interesting yeah
it's like they wanted it to get buried
under the news that's what comes to my
mind and I think when you look at it
they would be absolutely insane to pick
up that fifth year option so I think the
Bears you know I like some things
they've done with their roster but I
think it's gonna be a little bit of a
year of turmoil because I don't see how
much true Biscay can beat out Nick Foles
for that starting job these are the
scenarios where Nick Foles always seems
to gain momentum
Connor something crazy just happened at
146 cats and dogs are getting together
oil and water are mixing because the
Eagles traded with the Cowboys I don't
and the Jets traded with the Patriots
yesterday it's just a weird year ever
you know what everyone's coming together
we're all pitching in doing our part
everybody's friends today so they trade
up and take Tyler
be adesh the interior opens lemon for
Wisconsin to Travis Frederick retires
just go get another Wisconsin Badger who
play center but also has in very
concerns
so we're just replacing one guy with the
next to tyler banished from wisconsin
goes to the dallas cowboys yeah that's a
phenomenal pick the Cowboys just keep
doing really good things
yeah good value we're gonna break this
one down in a video so you'll get our
grades save it for there if you can't
Connor but someone who at one point
looked like a second-round player
there's just some major injury concerns
all right Dallas Cowboys get Tyler be
dish we're gonna break this thing down
the Dallas Cowboys lost Travis Frederick
to injury and then retirement and they
have drafted a man that might be able to
replace him in the fourth round Tyler be
an inch from Wisconsin where Travis
Frederick played center maybe a round 2
player at one point early and they share
we watched him open holes for Jonathan
Taylor together against Michigan but
there were injury concerns I know he's
never missed a game Badgers fans bees
had multiple surgeries and offseasons
scouts worried about his ability to stay
on the field long term I don't know that
you pencil him in as the starter they
drafted Connor McGovern in the 3rd round
last year but he can at least be a very
good third guard and backup center yeah
he'll come in and compete Matt and I
think would be a dish when you watch him
play he was the stalwart in front of
Jonathan Taylor now he did not look like
the same guy this year that we saw in
2018 where he looked like a potential
late first-round pick so I think when
you watch him play I think the concerns
were you know how much length does he
have that's why he moved inside the
center but a really really good down
blocker somebody that can probably play
Center end guard for you at the next
level and I think when he climbs to the
second level he did a good job of
getting his hands on defenders
especially linebackers reached blocks
double teams I think be a dish is just a
rock solid player I had a third round
great on him I love the pick for Dallas
it's gonna be an a for me in this spot
also in a 125 on my board I would not be
surprised if he has a year to sit and
Rehab a recover get his body right
wouldn't be shocked if we see another
Wisconsin Badgers starting a center for
the Dallas Cowboys
all right the Cowboys make the last pick
of the fourth round round 5 is here
we're gonna be with you until the end of
it Connor we have a saying on a stick to
football that we we stand a lot here
Missouri and we've given it to you and
Jersey we call it cutting time right
it's when you got to make a big decision
when you got step-up Jacob Eason
according to Zach Kiefer said as soon as
this virus calms down I'm gonna go in
there and compete my nuts off so Jacob
Eason is ready to go I respect that I
think him and Phillip Rivers are gonna
be really good friends now they might
speak a little different a little bit a
little different but yeah it's gonna be
fun I like that gonna compete his nuts
off Jacobs I think that's a great fit
for him very good fit all right round
five is here the Cincinnati Bengals are
on the clock is the
owners of the first pick in every round
this year the Cincinnati Bengals so we
will see where they continue to go as we
move to round five any huge surprises
for you Connor well let's look at the
board and see who's left I Matt did not
think Jake from and Hunter Bryant and
Bradley and I would be sitting here in
round five those feel like the biggest
Falls the Donovan people's Jones fall
it's not really shocking because I heard
a lot of teams just saw all athlete now
I thought Shay Patterson didn't give him
a chance but just because you and I were
higher on him and saw him as a third
round player doesn't mean the league
agrees so that's one I think there's
some value at wide receiver coming into
the fifth round right now I want to see
where Isaiah Hodgins goes as a
possession guy I want to see know where
Nick Harris goes as a center another
third-round player that has taken an
absolute tumble because his body has
just been falling apart is on its a
moody so the guard with very very short
arms but a powerhouse I'm not surprised
to see him fall although I love the
talent we have a special treat for you
guys here gridiron heights we're gonna
show you what's been cooking those guys
the best in the business absolutely love
it this is must watch so here's a little
sample of some grid iron Heights for you
tell you what man with his online drift
man that's why I moved in next to our
coach okay so the problem is that you
were using a computer like a whiteboard
okay what how do I another cube welcome
to this year's dress I can finally meet
my employees now we've created digital
recreation so that players can still hug
me I thought we programmed out the boos
all right first pick is the Bengals
you're on the clocks that Taylor Oh
return of Ezekiel with my first pick on
obviously taking
we've been hacked do you want to play oh
hell yeah I love my gates no one can
make us make terrible picks yeah I could
totally see them doing that okay the
Dolphins trap my mr. Winn hi baby yokes
with Kody parked publicly and
emotionally things from six feet away
you're going down Falls you give that a
weird career think who's the one person
that got beef with everybody nope not me
I'll take care now probably Jamis better
column hey coaches I just want you to
know I've been grinding working real
hard okay James just said you don't need
to meet this phone I don't think it's
him Patriots Oh we'll take to it I'm
watching your calls too okay let's cut
to our joint coverage of the draft
I just know you did introduce gridiron
hacks to my son this week because he was
like what cartoony watching why are you
watching cartoons you're a grown man
it's like you have to watch this like
it's the greatest thing ever
so Emmitt is now hooked on gridiron
Heights you're welcome Dennis sorry
let's take a look at the last five picks
because round five has started we had a
couple come off the clock these gyms are
ready to be done like Sean Payton looks
like he's ready to take a nap we've
already seen Roger Goodell's like
chilling in his lounge chair so we'll
get to those last five picks the Bengals
started this round we pick 147 the
Seahawks at 148 the Colts on the board
at 149 then we have the Giants at 150
the charges are 151 those are the first
five picks of round five we were talking
about the best player still on the board
Donovan people's Jones has fallen Jake
Fromm has fallen I think we're gonna see
a run on normally in round five you're
getting a run on receivers corners and
edge rushers because you're betting on
athleticism in these spots so I think
that's where we see two
go Connor yeah I think so too I think
we're gonna see you know we've seen two
different runs at wide receiver
obviously we had the wild wild you know
middle of the first round
the second round it really picked up it
completely hit a dead point Matt and
we're gonna see a pick back up just to
read some of those names Donovan
people's Jones Isaiah Hodgins KJ Hill
Colin Johnson Tyler Johnson JaJuan
Jennings Quinn says Cephas to deep
threats in a row you have Darnell Mooney
John Hightower so those are a lot of
names you're gonna hear them come off
the board here soon and I think outside
of the top players that we keep
mentioning that's the position group
where I still see some is some impact
talent because of the speed Conor Carter
Packham in the absent why is Bradley an
eye drop so low that is a great question
Carter Pat great question we don't know
we had them great a much higher thought
he had a very very good senior bowl
process good enough a pre-draft process
let me get you guys caught up on the
picks here real quick if we can because
some have come in we don't want you to
fall behind the Bengals are 147 khalid
creme edge from notre dame the seahawks
at 148 Alton Robinson an edge rusher
from Syracuse the Colts at 149 Danny
Pinter an offensive guard from Ball
State and the New York Giants at 150
offensive guard Shane Lemieux from
Oregon so two offensive linemen and two
edge rushers to start round five Connor
we're gonna break down Shane LEM you
give our fans a grade of those picks you
guys can see all those in the BR app
which hopefully that's where you're
watching so that you can leave comments
like Carter pack up did you get your
question answered we are ready Connor to
break down Shane Lemieux to the New York
Giants yep let's do it
the New York Giants continue to get big
physical movers on the offensive line
Shane Lemieux from Oregon six foot four
310 pounds a 5-1 one in the 40-yard dash
at the combine but my goodness he can
Maul people the Oregon offensive line
one of the best in college football last
year my biggest question was Shane
Lemieux the reason he was 181 on my big
board Connor
his feet are not good can this guy move
well enough to play as they started in
the NFL or he always gonna be a swing
guard maybe a backup tackle I'm with you
there Matt when you look at the Oregon
offensive line the guys that were draft
eligible for this year I thought he was
the best one I watched I had a
fifth-round grade on him and of course
he goes right here really at the top of
round five when you look at him you
nailed it
the feet are slow but I keep using this
phrase on the show if you've been
watching phone booth guy if he gets you
in that range it gets his hands on you
he can drive you backwards he could be a
good run blocker he's a projected backup
at the guard position he's a high
character leader Joe judge loves these
tough guys on the offensive line er
anywhere in the trenches so this is a
b-plus pick for me with the Giants I'm
not sitting here saying that Shane
Lemieux is gonna be this all world guard
starter I think he's your ideal backup
at guard that's a good run blocker that
you'll need to give a little a to and
pass protection yeah I'm giving him a
seat I thought a little bit of a reach
again you're probably in a backup
lineman being you see where they project
him if he stays the left guard if he
moves to be maybe a backup right tackle
but the Giants investing in the
offensive line here in the 2020 NFL
Draft
all right Giants get another lineman the
Chargers are on the clock at 151 and
they take one of my favorite players in
the class I tweeted this whoever gets
this player I'm a fan of your team the
LA Chargers get Joe Reed from Virginia
slot receiver playmaker punt returner
probably the best returner in a class
honestly so we're doing a video
iceman hopefully you you're just gonna
listen to me and I'm slow on slack right
now Joe Reed a huge wait we're calling
it audible we'll see what happens we got
Peyton Manning back here calling hot
routes
we're doing it all right there we go we
decided oh ma oh ma we're doing the
video
Joe Rashid going to the LA Chargers
there so many offensive weapons in the
West now my goodness
[Music]
the LA Chargers looked at the AFC West
and said like we got to do some speed at
receiver and they do it with Joe Reed
five kickoff return touchdowns in his
career averaged over 33 yards per punt
return
Annie has four for speed Connor Rodgers
he's built like a running back six foot
tall 224 pounds just get him the ball in
space let him return Joe Reed is one of
the most exciting playmakers with the
ball in his hands in this year's draft
class yeah Matt is a special teams pick
but it's a really really good one I
think when you look at Joe Reed he is
the best kick returner in this entire
class there is no doubt about that
and you could see some of the ability
with his ball in it with the ball in his
hands here he gets upfield good change
of direction constantly very very
elusive good body type to take those
hits on short passes and kickoff return
so I look at Joe Reed here I don't think
he's a complete receiver he's probably
guy that'll be a fifth wide receiver in
most of his career but such a good
special teams player that this is a nice
pick here to fill a need for the
Chargers I'm gonna go be - for Joe Reed
I'm this is the most excited I've been
for a round five pick maybe ever I'm
giving it an A+ Joe read is my guy
between about him for weeks now the
Chargers get Joe Reed slot receiver I
think could play some running back and
he's going to be a great return man the
AFC West you got score points to win
Joe Reed he's gonna help you do that an
A+ for a round five pick that's where we
are in the draft this year pick 151 Joe
read to the Chargers Matt I'm not really
a tree but I would love to take a moment
and as everybody on Twitter is asking
why is Bradley and I still on the board
all right so I've been asking around you
know as I can send text in between
videos I've got nothing back on that on
you know there's not the bad player I
don't know anyone who had him graded
this late I think that's a very very
good question of why would why would he
still be on the board this happens you
know somewhat often a good player falls
and we don't really ever get a great
answer on why here's a fun pick for you
the O'Connor the Carolina Panthers are
on the clock here at 152 overall they
just took a safety from the XFL
Kevin Love table
who was at West Virginia but he goes to
the XFL actually kind of takes advantage
of the rule there so kenny robinson
going from the XFL to the NFL ten years
doing the draft I've never said that
before but he is a very good athlete a
good player we're gonna break Kenny down
in a video the NFL's listing him is from
West Virginia my man just played a
season in the XFL oh what let's not
pretend alright we are gonna do a video
to break this down again Kenny Robinson
an interesting story coming from West
Virginia alright let's do this thing the
Carolina Panthers didn't have to go far
to scout this one Kenny Robinson a
safety from UC West Virginia cutter he
just played in the XFL for half the
season this past year took advantage of
that rule but Kenny Robinson an athletic
playmaker someone who has over-the-top
coverage skills I want to my talk to you
at the combine by he might go in the
third round the Panthers get him in the
fifth this is a bargain and a player
with a ton of upside who's already
played some professional football
phenomenal pick Matt a really
interesting story with Kenny Robinson he
was a first-team all-big 12 player at
West Virginia I think he was
academically ineligible he was kicked
off the program he goes to the XFL to
make some money and help his family it's
actually a phenomenal story and he plays
very well with grown men one of the
youngest players if not beat
youngest player in the XFL and he holds
his own good coverage ability good
tackler great ball skills
I like this pick a lot a great third
rotational safety that can give you some
juice and coverage this is an A+ pick
for me I thought this guy would have
been a third round fourth round pick he
falls in the draft I don't know if teams
just forgot to watch him because he was
in the XFL but if they did they made a
mistake I was gonna put an X on there
but I thought people make it bad it's an
a pick for me he was my number 96
overall player again I thought he had a
chance to go late round 3 the number 7
safety in this entire class
the Panthers get a steal and Kenny
Robinson from West Virginia ok you asked
me about Bradley and I we do a video
people start texting me about it so
thank you to all the people who are
watching who are responding to my text
appreciate you here Zoe for Connor
short arms at 32 and and 8 so that's an
issue for a
lot of teams bad 40 here an a let me see
here he ran a 493 that is not good at
6-3 257 so the bad 40 the short arms no
injury thing to worry about I think
people are just looking at the times
that and not looking at the tape which
see this happen I get I think this
happens every year to a pass rusher yeah
I thought to be clear here I don't think
Bradley and I is Von Miller or Khalil
Mack but I think when I watch the player
and understand what he is Matt he was
not good against the run you don't want
him s a three down edge defender right
now you want to put him in on third down
as a situational pass rusher great first
step and he has a plan counter move
cross face rip dip spin move we've
really seen the complete don't just walk
into double-digit sacks in the pac-12
for a defense like that and all those
defensive backs that have been drafted
already he was the one winning getting
dead getting downhill getting after the
quarterback giving them the time and
coverage or the lack of time Connor
we're at pick 153 in the 2020 NFL Draft
and 10,000 people are watching this on
YouTube right now it's amazing how some
people one of them the draft fans are
amazing we love you guys for sticking
with this all year here the BR app on
YouTube
in the six football podcast community
amazing when I started doing this 10
years ago if you told me hey in 2020
you're gonna be covering the draft and
10,000 people are gonna watch you on
YouTube would have blown my mind can't
even believe it crazy we appreciate you
guys for allowing us to do this we have
a trade here the 49ers trading with the
Miami Dolphins coming up to pick 153 the
Niners made news today trading for Trent
Williams the expectation Joe Staley is
going to retire at 35 years old they
replaced him a Trent Williams who
Washington he sat out the past year in
Washington so we'll see what the Niners
do at 153 the best players on the board
not a lot that you would say oh yeah
nine years ago to grab that guy Brice
hollow stone the board I know there's
some confusion earlier thanks to Twitter
Donovan people's Jones is there Stanford
Samuels the corner from Florida State I
actually think he's a really really good
fit here with 31 and is 31 to 3/4 arm
linked six one 187 so Stanford Samuels
would be a scheme fit for me we're
waiting to get the picker we'll see what
they do
okay excuse me let me back up the Niners
traded excuse me
the Niners traded Matt breda to the
Dolphins yeah this pic Wow some Matt
Breda goes to the Dolphins we said they
needed another running back they get one
Matt Breda speedster goes to Miami and
the Niners get a fifth round pick which
they desperately needed do you do you
think they just take another running
back with it so no so here's the pick
don't love it as a Niners fan Colton the
kibitz the oven's to tackle from West
Virginia ok quite sure he lifes think
you have just in school who's a good
backup tackle so Colton McKibben's West
Virginia offensive tackle going to the
San Francisco 49ers I'd rather have Matt
burrito the gold McKim it's just being
honest
yeah
you
the end of the video will explain why
you
in space that's the key so I had a C on
I wouldn't put a C on this pick had we
graded it just not a huge fan for the
knife so I like holding the kibitz the
thing here is why are you taking a
tackle when you just trade it for Trent
Williams do you are you that uncertain
about his injury history why he missed
the 2019 season with in addition to the
holdout
you would need to take another tackle so
cold Mike if it's here like that's okay
it's not a bad value he's gonna be a
good backup tackle but gosh it just does
not feel like this was a top meet again
as I said before Justin's school had to
fill in for Joe Staley this past year
it's a good player like they have good
depth in the offensive line yeah so my
understanding is I actually asked an NFL
offensive line coach about McKibben's
and they said they really liked him at
guard not tackle now I watched the film
and I watched him at tackle Matt I did
not see a good player a player that was
not in the top 200 they feel that the
conversion to guard will go really
really well
that's up in the air I think that's what
the Niners have to be thinking here
because I just don't think he's a guy
that will survive a tackle and like you
said Matt they kind of seem kind of set
in stone at that position right now no
you're absolutely right if he moves into
guard that's the need for the Niners so
if you were projecting him at inside
where lakyn Tomlinson and Tom Compton
aren't really getting fans excited at
the guard position and that was
somewhere where we thought maybe they
could have gone in round one even with
Cesar Ruis so this was an area that they
had to get better at if you're moving
him inside then I do like this pick a
little bit better for our 49ers my 49ers
not our 49ers so Miami is my careful
over from NFL Network is reporting that
the Dolphins tried to trade for Leonard
fournette instead they trade it for Matt
Breda so the Dolphins who being
aggressive about the running back
position yeah and two players that could
not be more different from each other
the reason I'm confused of trying to
trade for Leonard fournette didn't they
just sign Jordan Howard they did they
did so join Howard I mean we've seen him
bounce around a little bit so the Miami
Dolphins had a pick here so they're
gonna pick it 154 they're gonna get
Jason Strowbridge kind of edge rusher
defensive line a hybrid
North Carolina a player I was not super
high on but started to come around on
the power to his game he was a player
that was hard to figure out what the
conversion was gonna be so have him at
six forty to seventy five to Henry
Anderson we're not doing a great on this
one Connor so I had about one forty six
and what I was saying there I was very
low on him early in the process but as
we went back and kind of rechecked
things as I talked to our assistant
scouts about hey who do we who do we
like would we not like Strowbridge is
someone whose name came up a lot and the
Chicago Bears have traded with the
Minnesota Vikings all these inner
divisional traits things we've never
seen before
the Bears trade up yeah we had the news
earlier about mr. Biscay got to connect
these dots and think that maybe this is
where Jake Fromm goes that would be
something because then you are
definitely carrying three quarterbacks
throughout the year that you feel like I
mean there's no developing with from you
feel like what you have with them is
what you're gonna get so that would be
interesting to me Matt and I could see
it as well it seems like a kind of guy
that you have behind Nick Foles while
you move on from Schmidt sure Biscay in
2021 going back to Strobridge real quick
he was a guy that debuted for me at
number 200 there was somebody that I
have found the week of the draft that I
liked and moved in so he felt at 2:01
all power in his game I didn't see
anything else so you wonder how that
converts to the next level so you know
50 spots early eight not my favorite
pick yeah yeah I again I the value for
me was absolutely okay it's just a
little surprising with some of the other
players who were on the board I know
we're getting a lot of questions about
guys who are available Prince t go want
to go from Auburn why is the other board
I think that newness to football I think
there's some injury concerns there
excuse me Thaddeus Moss is still
available in round five a good another
player who came out of LSU early still
on the board I think there was always
more appeal to Thaddeus Moss with the
name than the play yes and no disrespect
him as a player a good player but not
someone that I had him ranked at 124 so
those look at the big boards Donovan
peoples Jones gonna send some text find
out why he's still available Stanford
Samuels I knew I was higher on Stanford
Samuels in the NFL loss I'm okay with
that let's check back in three years and
see where he should have been drafted
Jake from Bradley and I on the board for
both of
it gave davis came off the board
actually so what will update that get
you guys an update a pic so the Bears
made their selection and it is not Jake
from it is not a quarterback it is a
pass rusher Travis Gibson a defensive
end so another kind of long athletic
pass rusher we saw that you're Leonard
Floyd's gone they bring in Robert Quinn
but they get Travis Gibson from Tulsa
who I got 122 overall so this is
actually a really good value for the
Bears here at 154 I was looking at that
as well I know I had a 5th round great
on the guy so he probably should have
gone just a little bit higher than that
this is actually a good pick and
somebody that began to slide I had him
154 he went 155 hard to have any
disagreements with that all right let's
break it down in a little video if I can
get my iPad to work all right we'll
break this down Connor get you great
already well hop into this video Travis
Gibson goes to the Bears the Chicago
Bears lose under Floyd they bring in
Robert Quinn and now they get another
pass rusher in Trevis Gibson from Tulsa
6-3 to 61 a strong player 225 bench reps
at the combine here's the fun thing Mike
comprehend was Doris Armstrong Torrance
Armstrong who's a very good athlete I
think that's what you're getting from
Gibson someone who can fill out that
frame still a little bit but you see the
first step quickness he uses his link
exceptionally well counter he was 122 on
my board so I thought this is a
fourth-round player where'd you have
Gibson rated I had him 154 and he goes
155 so sometimes things there you go I
like that Matt and I actually thought he
would go a little later than this just
because he's so wrong but I was betting
on the athlete you nailed it first step
very very good some really good pass
rush traits and you're seeing it against
Michigan State it's not like he just did
it against low level of competition I
thought the motor ran very very hot to
be able to turn like that and his size
is really really impressive got some
stand-up reps in as well so hand in the
dirt stand up good speed can turn at
that size like I said a raw player
you're looking for more production
they're looking to develop him this is a
B+ for the Bears this value makes sense
the need makes sense it's a good fit
good developmental player
yeah absolutely here b-plus for me as
well I like that they're adding another
piece to this you don't just have to
rely on Clio Mac play in and play out
get this guy into the rotation Travis
Gipson from Tulsa joins Ryan pace and
the Chicago Bears in round five
we got another pick on the clock at 156
the Washington Redskins selected Keith
Ismael an interior offensive lineman
most likely Center from San Diego State
no video on that one no great on that
one excuse me Connor so if you need to
break down key the ESMA hood you
definitely can I think he's a little bit
undersized probably gonna be a sinner he
was on number 13 rated interior
offensive linemen in this class but it
is a thin Center crop so if you wanted
to get a center in Washington this is
the guy to do yeah that's exactly right
he was my 19th rated interior offensive
line guy but it's really down to him or
Nick Harris at this point for Center and
I know people have body type and
strength concerns with Nick Harris when
you look at Keith this mile it's
somebody that you know once again the
size wasn't great but I thought he moved
pretty well and we're at the point of
the draft where you're looking for
backup players at that position yep
Conor we cannot forget to thank our
presenting sponsor rocket mortgage and
people across the country are joining
together to say thank you to all the
essential workers who leave their homes
every day so the weekend stay home would
be safe in hours share your thanks for
the folks on the front lines by posting
your thank-you video to everyone knows a
hero dot come again thank you to rocket
mortgage by Quicken Loans and thank you
to all the essential workers who are
allowing us to do things like have the
NFL draft this weekend which feels a
little bit like normal we got a couple
pigs who have come in the Redskins kids
yzma Ismail at 156 the Jags are on the
clock at 157 and I believe I'll have
that pic momentarily the Jets are up at
158 so okay here's the pic at 157 Daniel
Thomas a safety from Auburn
I liked Daniel Thomas a lot I think
there's just questions about athleticism
using in the Box safety this is about
where he was expected to come off so
Jacksonville gets another good defender
from a big program in Daniel Thomas
they've just loaded up on them in this
class on defense across the board and
I thought of pretty sure area explosive
guy I do wonder about the range like you
said but Auburn always has these squatty
tough guys that play in a box like
Daniel Thomas and probably somebody that
you're looking to play special teams as
well yep what's funny about Daniel
Thomas there would be game she was like
gosh he's just not doing anything and
then he plays Alabama and I was like the
game of his life so he did play better
against good team so hopefully hopefully
we'll see him develop a little bit in
Jacksonville but he is one of my one of
my favorite day three players that were
seeing don't forget Connor and I are
here with you until the end of round
five you can get breakdowns of the best
teams the winners and losers still in
the app throughout the rest of the draft
so there's be a lot of fun for you guys
to check out in the app don't leave it
went around five ends there's certainly
plenty of content in there all right
Donovan people's Jones why is he falling
hopefully get that information very soon
the Jets are on the clock at 158 Connor
any hopes any predictions who the Jets
are gonna take here so I would like to
see them we still have Bryce Hall on the
board correct I haven't been faked out
again though he's actually confirmed on
the board still so I would take the
swing at Bryce Hogs with the Jets are on
wind now mode where you can draft and
stash him I'll tell you Matt I would
really like to see this team double-dip
at wide receiver
I like PJ here I like Isaiah Hodgins
I even have KJ Hill Colin Johnson Tyler
Johnson all fourth round grades so I
think the value here is still pretty
good
I thought JaJuan Jennings I don't care
that he can't run that dude is tough as
nails physical yes tight end yeah
exactly so I think when you look at it I
would take Bradley and I I'm tired of
saying it I really am tired of saying it
the Jets can load up a double dip at
wide receiver or edge pass rush but
they'll do something different every
time I go on these rants you chime in
and go I have the pick and then it's
like what I don't have it yet I'll let
you know as soon as we do jets on the
clock at 158 Jay Martinez in the app
said why wouldn't Jake from make a good
backup to Big Ben they want to throw the
ball down the field in that Pittsburgh
offense that's where Jake from his week
he's also not a very strong arm not a
very big player Pittsburgh is gonna get
cold it's gonna get windy
and that's gonna be an issue so Jake
from not a great pick for the Steelers
in my opinion that's why we're not also
seeing him like go to Tampa where you're
gonna want to be aggressive and throw
the ball down the field Connor if you
just had to pick a scheme fit for Jake
from what makes the most sense to you I
mean I if you were to say like New
England Minnesota maybe Chicago with
that West Coast type passing offense to
Matt naggy has what do you like him for
Jake from it would be New Orleans for me
Matt I think when you look at the short
area intermediate touch kind of throws
now my question is I don't know if and
you think of when Teddy Bridgewater had
to start think of that for Jake from he
sits on the bench behind drew Brees he
comes in and Teddy got labeled as game
manager but Teddy actually was allowed
to do things this year to go win the
game I think Jake from can grow into
that role in New Orleans so that would
be the offense for me a place where the
offense and let's not forget Matt Jake
Fromm got to play with two first-round
tackles you know I mean Andrew Thomas I
say Wilson even Salomon Kinley in front
of him DeAndre swift next to him a lot
of help there he needs to go somewhere
where there's a really good offensive
line so if you've missed it on day 1 day
2 there is a drinking game at one of our
listeners Andrew Magnus in the sticky of
the year we give out awards because we
like our listeners and every time Connor
touches his hair folks are supposed to
drink and I know you're touching Nate
IFB but every time you do it I am dying
over here laughing like they go to go on
a solo shot you'll check your you know
adjust these things cuz they're not very
comfortable and people are just chugging
right now hopefully it's a mimosa or a
screwdriver we don't want you guys just
going straight Jack Daniels it I guess
is I tried to c41 Easter's here yeah I
tried to save the people this year when
that when the b-roll goes up is when I
usually either fix the IFB give the hair
a little swipe but today Matt that
Saturday the draft there's no rules it's
always just no no it's justice sitting
here let go finally gets a day off the
men never gets a day off ever so there's
no rules no rules at all patch ambulance
says Conor touches hair drink Rakeem
said will the Bucks go offense or
defense with their next pick I
yes I'll predict offense on that I think
Bruce Arians is gonna want to get
himself some weapons we have a fake Melo
account saying
Carolina for Jake from apparently you
have it there's the at Connor Rogers fan
now there's a fake mellow account just
Carolina fit for from I actually think
that does fit for Jake from like you
said depth eighty bridge one of the
things they brought in PJ well Matt so
they lack their backup Matt yes sir gets
took Jets took Price Hall there you go
buddy that's that's good value I'm a
realist that does not believe in the
Jets winning this year I like taking a
player that you can stash and get him
right especially it's a good fit with
Greg Williams it is a good fit in the
scheme fits phenomenal if you've been
with this since we were there and they
said the Chiefs picked him we broke down
Bryce hall but he the top player
available on my board the second-highest
player available on yours and that the
technique from him list was clean the
Jets had I'm not saying as a cop the
Jets have had some success with players
like Durrell Riva so you don't always
get great speed
you have great technique so we have to
put a grade on this one because I know
Connor is happy I've do the Jensen made
some questionable or curious picks here
on day three you have Brice Hall in the
fifth round we're gonna break this thing
down get that grade ready
[Music]
the New York Jets needed an outside
corner and they get maybe the steal of
the draft the number 66 player on my big
board Brice Hall from Virginia here's
the biggest question on this guy
injuries that happen earlier this year a
broken ankle that was pretty gnarly and
Connor before the injury he was not
super fast this is your team this is
your crew
the Jets get a corner that we both had
graded in round two of this year's draft
yeah absolutely love Price Hall I mean
when you look at the player the injury
sucks because Matt he probably would
have been a top 50 pick without it I
mean this was somebody on the outside
that's a press corner that can run down
field 20 18 he leads the FPS with a
million pass breakups it felt like he
plays the ball phenomenally knows how to
find the ball he's physical he can jam
if it's very very well with Greg
Williams wants to do and the Jets know
about draft stash corners coming off
injury they did this last year with
Bliss on Austin and he finished the
season very strong when he got right to
play they're gonna do the same thing
with Brice Hall well I think you're
looking at a 2021 full-time starter and
love the rate here yeah I mean I pad was
completely frozen but it's the sloppiest
a plus you'll ever see I'm very happy we
did this earlier when we got fake down
and thought he was going to the Chiefs
he was my second top rated player
available top player on the board for me
a plus for the Jets haven't loved all
the pics that you guys have made this
year but this is a big one Brice Hall
goes to the New York Jets in the fifth
round
well Connor the Jets pick a player the
Patriots are up right after that and
they took Justin roar Wasser the kicker
from Marshall we are not at all grading
this video one of my favorite moments
ever a bleach report when Chris Sims
still worked here the kicker got drafted
when a guy who got picked in the second
round Sims is like you don't pay me to
Scout kickers I'm not doing this video
you know and so this is much better
range for a kicker to come off the board
yeah I think when you look at it this
wasn't even on my list of three kickers
or specialists that I had so I don't do
anything about the Marshall kicker I
know the hot rod I know Braden man the
punter
I know Turk that's about what it bar
Belichick drafts you as a kicker you're
a hall-of-famer
you hairy Gus Kowski and just like Tom's
just draft kickers whose last names are
gonna give us all hell basically that's
what they're doing here yeah that's
alright let's very early Matt it is
we're getting late billon kickers no no
like all challenge bill on D B's a
little bit but not hug kickers like
Jordan Richards in the second round I'm
gonna make fun of you and maybe the dog
made the pick as they said in our slack
Channel
the Browns pick is in I don't know if
our guys in the back have this yet so I
apologize for not putting in the slack
channel but Nick Harris the sinner from
Washington we were just talking about
him you like Nick Harris if you want to
run his own scheme because he's a little
bit undersized but a good athlete not
he's got a dad bod he's gonna have to
work on that a little bit and I'm not
shaming the mantas are you you know what
Mike Vrabel loves those so do we
so Nick Harris at 162 the Cleveland
Browns who have done a good job of
addressing that offensive line we are
not putting a grade on this one for the
dog pounders Connor if you have like a
lots on Nick Harris I like Nick Harrison
the 5th round my main concern with him
was play strengthen anchoring he is a
smaller guy he is about as small as you
can be for an offensive lineman but when
move like him off the snap and get
outside let's remember Kevin Stefanski
coming over a guy that learned from Gary
Kubiak they want to maybe get that
outside zone cooking and that's not a
one-year transition that might take a
little time so I think when you look at
Nick Harris he's somebody that is good
value at this point of the draft I'm
looking at my board right now Matt I had
him at the top of Round four yeah I did
as well I had him at 130 overall and as
you said he is as small as you can get
six one 300 pounds at the center
position but excellent movement his own
blocking scheme I'm reading my scouting
notes here but his movement skills
I put three plus signs by that I think
that's pretty good
I don't blocker yeah small but quick
you're at a 5-1 in the forty at six one
you know 320 pounds or 300 pounds that's
what you want so Nick Harris the Browns
maybe need to get younger JC Treader in
there at center Deb Joel boo Tanya Wyatt
teller at guard they put tit they took
excuse me judge Wilson the first round
got Jack Conklin afraid you see so big
changes to the offensive line for the
Browns so far in this draft all right
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers are up but 161
we had a question earlier do they go
offense or defense we'll find out the
Redskins at 162 but before we do that
Connor let's take one last one more look
excuse me at our presenting sponsor
rocket mortgage big special shout outs
all the essential workers out there I
want to say thank you to my sister joy
thank you thank you thank you sir
[Music]
everyone knows a hero calm go there now
if you have another device go there
tonight leave your video thank an
essential worker something again we will
all be doing thank you to everyone who's
allowing us to do this now counter folks
who follow us on Twitter I have seen
there's been a little bit of an argument
over the year of where a certain player
would be drafted there's a fan base that
loves him there's some fantasy football
folks who love him oh boy Tyler Johnson
a wide receiver from Minnesota and
sometimes in this business you put your
money where your mouth is and so I told
them if he was drafted in the first
round I would donate $1,000 to the
charity of their choice so he was
drafted in the second round a third
round I'd donate $500 to the charity of
their choice he just came off the board
in the fifth round to the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers Tyler Johnson goes to Tampa
and I like this fit for him this is
where he was supposed to come off the
board so Tyler Johnson joins Tom Brady
in Tampa Bay so what do you donate a bag
of chips I'm sorry I couldn't hear
Connor I was reading the comics we're
gonna grade this one so get your grade
ready I don't think anyone has to donate
to my foundation for getting that one
right
fifth round for Tyler Johnson we're
gonna put some grades on that and and
you know explain a little bit why
sometimes your how to find a player as
everyone else is but again Tyler Johnson
goes to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers Tom
Brady gets himself a slot receiver here
we go Tom Brady goes to Tampa Rob
Gronkowski goes to Tampa they need a
slot receiver and oh boy did they get
some production in Tyler Johnson from
Minnesota over the last two years one of
the most productive players in college
football great a contestant catches he's
a physical route runner the questions
Connor the reasons that he falls to
around five some folks have this player
with a round one great out in the draft
community he falls here though not great
separation the speed is not there a lot
of drops on tape he opted not to perform
at the Shrine Bowl opted not to perform
at the combine then quarantine say he
can't go to a pro day I had him at 142
overall on my board Connor where did you
have Tyler Johnson
yeah so he was my best receiver
available here now besides Donovan
Peoples Jones I had him as an early
fourth rounder and when you look at the
player on tape I thought he was the most
reliable target in that Minnesota
offense he's a very very tough player I
thought he was very consistent now you
do worry about the drops of course Matt
and you bring up a great point that the
draft process for him was bizarre so he
finished that 127 overall for me when he
could have been much higher we didn't
get to see him work out we didn't get to
see him in all-star games but he was a
really good player in college football
time and time again so is he the best
athlete is he the biggest guy we don't
know anything about the character
because we didn't get to see him in any
part of the process really those are the
questions up in the air but I'd like the
team fit and I had him in the fourth
round he goes in the fit to a good team
so I'll give this an A for Tyler Johnson
here yeah I gave it a B+ I know a lot of
people think oh I I don't like this
player I like this player in this spot
coming off the board of 161 I had him at
142 on the board so the value is good I
worry Tom Brady has not had a lot of
luck with receivers who can't separate
those that's for me something to watch
Tyler Johnson joining the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers all right he comes off the
board and cliquey Hudson goes 162
outside linebacker from Michigan goes to
the Washington Redskins he might play
some safety as well kind of a versatile
piece and I don't mean to be like
self-serving let's talk about Tyler
Johnson just a little bit longer this is
important talking point it is because
again a lot of folks the Pro Football
Focus had him as their number one
receiver prospect in this draft I
believe so there's a lot of confusion
why does it player like that fall down
board so I'm gonna go back to something
that I said I believe in October or
November of this year on our stick to
football podcast area scouts were
telling me they were not getting good
character reports back that doesn't mean
a player's been arrested or failed the
drug test sometimes that can mean work
ethic it could mean maturity we talked
about it with Jacob Eason when we had
him on our show and it's a recent he
fell in the draft Tyler Johnson did not
handle the pre-draft process well he
didn't he opted not to go to the Shrine
game after not getting a senior bowl
invite he needed to do that he needed to
approve himself then he decided not to
run at the the combine or do anything at
the combine other than position drills
that affected his talk I like Tyler
Johnson in the fifth round but those are
three questions this isn't me like
trying to hurt a kids draft stock you
want to see everybody succeed but when
area Scouts who go into the schools tell
you hey yeah there are some concerns
here and it's gonna cause him to fall in
the draft on top of drop questions and
speed questions so we can finally put a
button on it I hope Tyler Johnson has
one of those careers that I can see him
with a Super Bowl in a cup here and say
hey I'm happy for you
you've outplayed expectations
congratulations that's the best moment
in this careers when a guy proves you
wrong yeah no doubt man I think it
speaks the part of the job is I think
two things we do we speak to when we
really like players and we're open and
honest that we're probably higher or
lower on players than the general
consensus or the Gennifer general NFL
Scouting departments and all of those
things another thing we do is we try to
be realistic and prepare you for where
players are gonna go and I think for a
long time there was this sense that
Tyler Johnson was a second-round talent
or a second-round player and the reality
of the situation was he was always going
to be a day three player now I'm rooting
for him I think this is a good fit Bruce
Arians is obviously a player very
friendly coach you know player friendly
coach a good environment Tom Brady's the
veteran there that'll work with all
these guys you have veteran presence a
guy like Mike Evans Chris Godwin so when
you look at it this is the situation
where if you're a Tyler Johnson fan I
don't think you could have asked for a
better one I'm gonna be completely
honest with you use this scheme friendly
he has an opportunity for some targets
there's a veteran presence in the locker
room with a really good head coach but
the reality of the situation is he was a
fifth round pick so we're gonna see what
happens
yep and the Bears are on the clock at
163 it looks like make sure we're caught
up here so that the Redskins take leakey
Hudson outside linebacker safety from
Michigan the Bears at 163 Connor they go
Kendallville door a big corner from a
small school Georgia southern we got a
chance to see him in person at the
Senior Bowl this year 510 but he's 191
so he's got a very good frame good arm
length and I didn't think when we saw
him play against those power five
receivers at the Senior Bowl he didn't
look out a place down there i he was one
of my risers from that week yeah I
thought so too I mean I'm looking at the
board here I don't have a lot of corners
left ahead of this
sky right now especially with Bryce Hall
off the board so I liked him think I had
him around 190 but we're at the point of
the draft where you're gonna get you
know reaches by 30 spots because of
needs and developmental players I think
the athleticism stands out to me Matt
and like you said he never really looked
lost on the field against higher
competition so you know you go through
bill towards numbers I don't know if
we're gonna do a video here but
explosive I mean it looks do or 440
alright we're gonna do the video so
we'll save it the Chicago Bears get
another corner to go with Kyle fuller
and that's Kendall
ville door from Georgia southern 510 191
we got to see this guy in person in the
senior but where he had a pick six in
that game and really stood out against
bigger competition from the LSU
Alabama's Ohio State's and Georgia's
Connor he was one of my risers of the
week now I had about 170 for the value
here for the Bears it's good but I like
that they're being aggressive there
aren't many corners better than him left
on my board so where they get him is a
pretty good value yeah it's the same for
me Matt one of the best corners
available on the board right now a very
thick frame 510 191 so he's very
muscular physical and you see that the
catch point there he's going up against
Clemson wide receivers this guy will
drop his shoulder to tackle short area
quickness is very good 39 and a half
vertical that is phenomenal 133 broad
jump so when you watch him play he is
explosive he can leap with big bodied
receivers down the field where that 510
height it's just not really a concern
for me in the arms 32 and a quarter
that's really good for a 5 foot 10 guy I
like this a pick a lot here Matt I'm
actually gonna give it an A in this spot
there we go I'm gonna give this one a B
if I pick up my tablet I like build or I
like the upside anybody take someone
here can you play special teams
yes can he play in the nickel yes he can
play in the slot as well I think the
arrow is putting way up on billboard for
the Chicago Bears
all right as we move along pick 164 the
Philadelphia Eagles are on the clock so
we are cooking and the Eagles are
trading never mind the Eagles don't want
to make any more picks they're tired of
us making they're tired they do need fun
out of their yep and so the Miami
Dolphins have traded up to 164 and they
take Curtis Weaver defensive end okay
Boise State we'll talk about him if we
do a video also I just got told yes the
Eagles have traded for Marcus Goodwin so
the Niners trade another player Matt
breed is gone marquise Goodwin is gone
so I'm not even good I don't know if I'm
even gonna recognize my favorite team
next year
like it's gone Joe Staley is gone
I do too they need speed at receiver
they get it with arguably the fastest
guy in football yeah and we added a
little bit of injury concerns with Jalen
rhaegar so you're getting yourself some
insurance for your first-round pick as
well let's do Curtis Weaver he deserves
to be talked about this his moment we're
gonna break that down we're gonna grade
the pick again Curtis Weaver
comes off the board from Boise State
going to the Miami Dolphins that pick
160 for the Miami Dolphins loaded up on
pass rushers in free agency and they
just got another one in Curtis Weaver
from Boise State a productive pass
rusher but Connor you probably noticed
in the clip there our guy got a little
heavy this past year and it affected his
draft stock there were a lot of concerns
about strength and conditioning that
body started to get heavy
he had an illness preseason I was told
by area Scouts it affected him from
working out the Dolphins are hoping they
can get that ironed out so that he's
ready to join players like Jason
Strowbridge who they drafted it earlier
in round five to really fortify that
pass rush
and even through the sloppy weight-gain
man this was a really really productive
pass rusher it's really impressive how
he got it done I'm looking at my board
here I had the guy at 118 you see the
stand-up brush good hands that's where
he wins he keeps offensive lineman's
hands away from him blockers hands off
of him I think he had pretty good
closing bursts once he got in the
backfield so when you watch Weber play
the motor runs pretty hot short the body
type not the best but he's gonna work on
that to get better and once again this
is a really good value tick because I
look at the Dolphins they keep taking
all of these runs stopping players and
they don't have a lot of guys with pass
rush juice off the edge so for me this
is a guy that once again if you get that
conditioning right in the Miami strength
program and Brian Flores he's gonna be
tough on these guys I like it this is an
a for me for the Dolphins at this point
of the draft I feel like he should have
went probably 30 spots earlier Conner we
were in Miami for eight days for the
Super Bowl he'll sweat off all that
weight that's why I did while I was
there had a round three great on Curtis
Weaver so Street conditionings Brian
Florence is gonna iron that out and you
might have yourselves a starting
defensive end in round five if not the
tacos and margaritas will do it I was
just gonna say that not to give too much
information eight days of Miami is a
long time three times but a long time
all right time B it is the Jacksonville
Jaguars I believe will be on the clock
so the Eagles trade for Marquis Goodwin
yeah it's just tough when your favorite
team like George Kindles all holding on
to now as an i Hearst fan if he goes
anywhere I'm officially petitioning to
JumpShip here's the best available
Williams yeah I don't know that's cool a
good player I'm happy with that I am
happy with that all right the
Jacksonville Jaguars we're not I believe
I believe we're not breaking this one
down but they did take a player that I
like a lot Jacksonville Jaguars at 165
hook em horns Connor Rodgers they get
Colin Johnson the 6-foot
215 pounds I got every way our guy just
couldn't stay healthy hell of a player
couldn't stay healthy over the last two
years throw him back yeah bait as though
two is gonna love that yeah he couldn't
stay healthy unfortunately I the catch
radius
you know very impressive on the field
that was what's today's a noctilum
Johnson he is an octopus and he's just
he's taller than everyone else out there
and I think he's you know very
competitive I think it's almost like we
we misdiagnosed a guy just because he's
hurt you forget how the level of
competition I think Colin Johnson we saw
at the Senior Bowl went down to
one-on-ones and really got after it with
everyone so I like him I think this is
late for him I remember Matt talking to
you before the season we went down to
Texas together and we were talking to a
lot of different people or like man
Colin Johnson you know probably guy that
you and I were lower on we thought he
was a top 60 pick while some people
thought he could be a top 40 pick now he
falls all the way to the fifth round so
and this is great value you had about
111 overall my favorite Colin Johnson
nugget his best friend on the team was
the center you just don't see that very
often like wide receivers don't hang out
with linemen that's that's rare so great
character great work ethic huge frame
excellent length I think a player who
was hurt by injuries as we said but also
not getting a 40 timeout there before
quarantines that affected him because
that's the biggest question but up my
comp Jags fans was Plaxico Burress so
big upside there on six six 222 just
throw the ball up throw the ball up to
this guy yeah without a doubt if you can
keep him on the field he's a productive
player and speaking of guys being
friends Matt one little note in here
when the Jets the Jets drafted cam Clark
apparently him and Makai Becton are like
best friends
so that's gonna be an interesting bully
tandem on the same side together yeah
there you go just get to bruisers it's
like when you and I go places on
tailgate or friends we have our friends
our rocket mortgage and people across
the country are joining together to say
thank you to all the essential workers
who leave their homes every day so we
can stay safe in our share your thanks
for the folks on the front line by
posting your thank you video to everyone
knows a hero calm everyone knows hero
calm thank you again to rocket mortgage
by Quicken Loans for making all of this
possible for us along with those
amazingly important and special
essential workers who are allowing us to
do things like the NFL Draft right the
Detroit Lions around the clock at 166
they take a wide receiver from Wisconsin
Quinton
Cephas who very very good vertical
threat physical watch the bull game if
you go watch one game watch the
Wisconsin ballgame this guy just
starched 50/50 balls it's like nope
those are mine
it's like watching Carl Malone rebound
when the ball goes up to quintet Cephas
is that my dad myself by saying Chrome
alone no not with me maybe with some of
our audience but when you look at me I
think Cephas I watch basketball hope one
of the more physical pass catchers we
have on the board here I think the main
concern with him was long speed in this
draft Matt it absolutely is long speed
was the question I ran up for seven
three but it can play inside six one two
oh two could play inside could play
outside again just throw the ball deep
to Quinn test Eavis Matthew Stafford
pretty strong arm I think they will find
a way to work together the Buffalo Bills
are up at 167 the Eagles 168 the Vikings
169 the Ravens at 170 just reminder that
Conor and I will be here with you until
the end of round five which the Cowboys
currently have that at pick 179 so we
are moving pal
so don't forget drop your comments in
the app as we wait for the NFL to catch
up to us they have to send their picks
in when we get them we tell them to you
guys so leave your comments below us in
the app we'll do our best to read them
while you can and don't forget to follow
the six football podcast on Twitter a
stick to football also on Instagram he
is at Connor Jay Rogers I am at NFL
Draft scout and sad news Joe Staley
officially retiring per his Instagram so
right Niners that I hack of a career
honestly all decade offensive tackle I'm
biased I think he's got to be at least
in the Hall a really really really good
if not the Hall of Fame and the
quarterback say he's blocked for I mean
it's been one hell of a run in San
Francisco for Joe Staley they did get
Trent Williams like you said trying to
cheer me up I appreciate that but Joe
Staley walking away from the NFL at 35
years old and I'm getting a kick as
they're showing the draft broadcast I
don't know why they have the Jets on
Adam GaSe and Joe Douglas that Adam
gazes son I think is wearing a levy on
Bell Jersey the irony of that just apps
I thought they like each other
absolutely kills me yep and we're gonna
ask so in the app can man 40
five ye is Donovan Peebles Jones falling
we are working on that he wants the
Packers to draft him at 175 that's a
good guy that fit I have been there's
one scout I've been texting with for
like three rounds I keep saying DPJ like
this team okay this team will take him
this team will take DPJ hasn't happened
yet so we'll see if someone gets him off
the board here we've had a little bit of
a run and wide receivers Colin Johnson
then Quintus Cephas the bills are up at
167 they've had a fun draft the Bills
have a japanesse exact moss just
continue to get good physical players
the bills due but where does down to my
peoples Jones go I wouldn't be upset if
the bills took him at all no I think
that is another spot that makes sense I
think you're just loading up on athletes
guys with a big catch radius for Josh
Allen so I'm I'm a little puzzled
because I we've seen Gamble's mat that
are not the athletic profile of DPJ at
this point is there something and I
don't mean to assume it's their
character thing like what I don't
injuries very injury the medical
character it's very bizarre to me at
this point
I also we have a picture bud yeah we
have a pic here 167 over I'll pick 167
the Buffalo Bills into the fall for Jake
from Jake from quarterback Georgia how
going to the Buffalo Bills
Josh Allen obviously is good he's the
starter the opposite of Josh Allen it
would come out as Jake from Oh exactly
like if he had an alter ego it would be
Jake from we have to do even as players
like we have this really accurate
quarterback who's very safe kind of
timid and then you have the other one
who's like let's just throw the damn
ball down there yeah no right not that
tall
maybe he'll transition to coach I'm
shocked that he was here at 167 we are
going to grade this one Jake from had a
fall but lands with the Buffalo Bills
will break this down and give our grades
giorgia quarterback Jake from leaves
Athens early as a junior we thought I
maybe goes round to maybe around 3 he
falls to round 5 the Buffalo Bills get
an absolute steal the number 77 overall
player on live big board Connor Rodgers
I counted this guy to Kirk Cousins maybe
just maybe he has a similar career where
balls in the draft becomes a starter and
then is getting paid mega money by a
team so Jake from are you surprised I
know we're surprised how shocked are you
that he is still available at this spot
in round 5 for the bills to draft him
I'm shocked at the same GM that took
Josh out and took Jake from because they
are so different from each other it is
unbelievable but let's start with the
good with Jake Fromm I mean number one
he was my 79th player on the board so
the value here is exceptional the
physical profile it's not gonna wow you
he throws with touch he's an accurate
thrower he's a pocket passer insane
insane high IQ he's very very smart
player he's really your prototypical
long-term backup a guy that can come in
and you hope can manage the game similar
to how a lot of people view Kirk Cousins
coming out or maybe even Teddy
Bridgewater before he got fully healthy
again but you watch Jake Fromme play I
think he's a guy that can really slow
the game down when he did you need a
good offensive line in front of him so
it's good the Buffalo has that you need
a power run game with him as well a lot
of things he had at Georgia but this
great value in this spot the Buffalo
Bills I like this a plus right here yeah
you have to give it an A+ when you get a
player who was ranked 77 overall at pick
167 even if he's just a really good
backup for four years there is value in
that so I like where Jake from goes like
you said a little bit of the anti Josh
Allen that's okay you don't have to have
a type Brandon bean gets his backup
quarterback in Jake from from the
University of Georgia
definitely a surprise here but you know
good for good for Jake from and I think
it shows the range of being like you
know how many GM's matter like I mean
especially when we talk to Scouts execs
GM's coaches they're like this is my
kind of guy and it's like you sit there
and you're just like it's interesting to
me of the kind of players they take and
don't take and for the bills I think
they don't have a type at any position
anymore without a doubt yeah and
normally you do hear that like you want
okay you have this guy you want this guy
you know Philip Rivers - Jacob Eason
those those make sense right you get
your backups locked in they're very
different here at 168th the Philadelphia
Eagles have drafted another speedy
receiver John Hightower from Boise State
yeah speedster deep threat when I look
at the board here right now that
completely checks out I saw I had
Hightower actually a little later than
this but I'm not surprised they also can
return kicks as well you know we'll
break this one down we'll get it grade
so our buddy Adam left coke can sit at
home and watch this grade in the
Bleacher Report app and see all the
funnies missing out on here on day three
the 2020 NFL Draft we are ready let's do
this video
Connor Rodgers
the Philadelphia Eagles continue to add
speed they've added jaylen rhaegar they
trade for Marquis doing now they get
John Pike our from Boise State four for
three in the 40-yard dash
you saw it on film you saw it at the
combine he's six one and a half 189
pounds that's why I compared him to
Robbie Anderson Connor but I had him 140
overall on my board so there you go
actually get a great value here in the
fifth round I was a little lower Matt I
think you look at it what bet what is
valuable is that straight line speed
that the Eagles keep targeting with
Hightower here he's a guy that can wind
downfield tracks the ball well obviously
very very explosive off the snap so I
think that's the big the big plus here
now you wonder how he's gonna handle
press coverage at the next level you see
he can really really get upfield in
advance and I think when you look at the
receivers left on the board there
weren't a lot of speed threats left I
like Donovan peoples Jones and Isiah
Hodges much better in this spot but it's
clear they value speed so it's a C+ for
me I thought this was a sixth or
seventh-round player it's a little early
I like other receivers better but once
again I understand the Eagles strategy
they just want guys that can get
downfield yeah I gave it an A+ I
actually loved the value of the only
thing I don't like necessarily is there
a feels like they're overloading at
receiver but that was their biggest
weakness last year so they're trying to
correct some of the problems that we saw
we didn't get production from JJ or Sega
Whiteside hopefully this year's receiver
class goes a little bit better for the
Philadelphia Eagles with John Hightower
from Boise State a new weapon for Carson
Wentz all right moving right along here
so I heard back on Donovan peoples Jones
for all the people asking got three
responses back that I have in front of
me at least one set and these are
unfiltered so I apologize if you guys
don't like thee this is what's coming in
one said incredibly soft another said
did not interview well third one said
always hurt drop too many passes so
those are your unfiltered takeaway about
yeah we wondered about medical and
character and we got every different
opinion on those yes so the Minnesota
Vikings on the clock at 169 and they're
just go show how important interviews
are if you don't interview well let's go
are you so the Minnesota Vikings select
Harrison hand a temple a cornerback
almost set a temple out of cornerback so
Harrison hand goes to the Vikings
another team Liberty like a very need
heavy draft so far and I think you have
to applaud that at least Connor we're
not gonna grade this one unload the
notebook on Harrison hand yeah I think
when you look at it a guy that actually
doesn't always fit their length profile
I would say I think he's not a small
corner but around 510 pretty good
recovery speed I think when you look at
it at you could play a lot of man
coverage which is what they're gonna ask
really projects as a fourth corner and
actually this is right where I thought
he would go right around the fifth or
sixth or maybe even early seventh round
but I think when you have the frame he
has very thick frame and enough recovery
speed that gets you drafted into a
scheme that I'll ask you to probably
play a lot of press coverage yeah item
at 215 overall so temple corner 215
overall here's the Ravens previous picks
they've had one heck of a draft probably
my favorite draft so far the Baltimore
Ravens Patrick Queen at 28 JK Dobbins
running back from Ohio State Justin mata
bouquet an interior pass rusher from
Texas AM Devin Duvernay hook him wide
receiver Texas and then Malik Harrison
the linebacker out of Ohio State
speaking of billing needs and the rate
was around the clock at 170 they've
checked all the boxes if you had gone
into the draft Thursday morning and said
this is what the Ravens have to do they
gotta do something with these picks this
is a team that was we thought was gonna
be a Super Bowl appearance this year
with how great that offense was how
tough the defense was and they've
checked all the boxes all these players
from big programs as well LSU Ohio State
Texas A&M Texas and Ohio State again so
it's that model of let's get producers
from big programs high character guys
you've got a couple team captains in
here this is this is my favorite draft
so far Connor how do you feel about it I
love it
it's either them or the Raiders I think
the Giants did really well actually
don't hate what my Jets did for once I
think when you look across the board a
lot of teams that well I think the
Ravens stand out amongst the pack
Patrick Queen had no business you know
waiting that long when you take all the
linebackers that went off the board
JK Dobbins great vision great
just a really pro ready runner bad at
bouquet could shoot gaps they like that
they like their interior guys to be able
to get after the quarterback Duvernay
insanely insanely explosive Malik
Harrison another guy maybe not the best
long speed but really good short area
quickness and a thumper down the middle
so when you look at what Baltimore's
done it's not shocking DeCosta they're
taking over for Ozzie Newsome the COTS
they learn from Ozzie for a very long
time Baltimore has the system with the
draft and it just works a year after
year yeah and whether you go from like
you said from Ozzie Newsome to eric
Jocasta they take care of their scouts
there it's one of the place Scouts want
to go work because Baltimore takes such
good care of them that's why they
consistently have good reps even in
round five we have nine more picks I
believe 179 the Dallas Cowboys will be
on the clock we're at 170 the Baltimore
Ravens after that Connor and I get to
hop off and do more work as we get ready
for to break down this draft we'll be
doing that long stick to football for
the next couple weeks and then it's on
to 2021 normally on a date three I would
beg them to let me go ahead and drop a
big board graphic and I do have one but
we're gonna wait we're gonna wait a
little bit longer Connor knows I'm
always itching to just go ahead and we
do this all the tradition like no other
um can I guess the top two let's do it
yeah we had a little time to kill good
I'm gonna say Trevor Lawrence penny
Sewell and then Jamar chase nailed it
the top three is pretty easy this
upcoming year 170 yeah it's easy and
then not so much my guy though Trey
Lance quarterback North Dakota State 20
touches last year no interceptions get
to know him get to know him a little bit
yeah all right Baltimore Robins that's
gone yeah I can't wait
170 Broderick Washington the edge rusher
from Texas Tech goes to the Baltimore
Ravens on a round seven grade on
Broderick Washington actually as we were
doing our day three mock drafts last
night I kept looking at Melo and our guy
big country who helps this and saying
this always had Broderick Washington
always falls in the draft and I have no
idea where to put him but item rated at
205 overall so just outside that top 200
that we've been referencing but he goes
here at 172 Baltimore yeah I think when
you look at the Ravens here I mean I
this is the first pick that I kind of
questioned the value I think it's the
first
we've seen from them where it's early
like you Matt this player was not in my
top 200 so a little bit surprise here
but I mean at this point I don't know
who to trust me or the Ravens that's the
problem it's great when that happens do
you like man I didn't like this player
but this team knows how to drop so we'll
just trust them let's take one more look
oh that's a hair touch you guys get a
drink that was a big hair touch you
might finish your drink on that one
let's take one more look at our
presenting sponsor rocket mortgage by
Quicken Loans and their video
everybody's hero calm being special
shout out to all the essential workers
out there I want to say thank you to my
sister joy thank you thank you thank you
sir
[Music]
so you've read the graphic don't listen
to me everyone knows a hero dot-com
check that out everyone knows hero com
upload your thank-you video to essential
workers Connor we are waiting for the
Houston Texans at 171 then the Detroit
Lions at 172 with the Eagles at 173 so a
couple more picks 179 again the Dallas
Cowboys is where round 5 ends the the
Texans took an offensive
they've gone offensive line in this
draft let's look at the top remaining
though again we've addressed why Donovan
people's Jones is on the board why is
Bradley and I still on the board we've
heard back from scouts on those players
kenny willa kiss a player a couple guys
here we've had on stick to football
kenny willikers hunter bryant aj green
at corner from oklahoma state still
available and then prince tiga wanna go
with offensive lineman from auburn yeah
I think when you look at this group
right here I mean you have two super
high character pass rushers at the top
and I Kenny willow kiss Hunter Bryant
still being there surprises me I didn't
think this tight end class was any good
but he was my second ranked tight end
and carried a third-round grade we heard
all your thoughts and responses on
Diamond pupil as Jones a guy that I like
I see on your list Matt AJ Green thought
he was a pretty physical corner I would
like to see somebody take a shot on him
in the fifth round here yeah absolutely
and the pick for the Houston Texans is
in they're going to take Isaiah Colter a
wide receiver from Rhode Island we're
gonna break this one down he's actually
one of the eyes and speed favorite
sleepers in this class so a lot of speed
for the Houston Texans now at wide
receiver we'll get our grades ready for
this one and I think Houston always does
this we like lock them trading people
like John Jay Hopkins and then you step
back and look at their draft class it's
like it's pretty good look it's not a
bad draft class when you get Ross black
lock jonathan Greenert now you had
Isaiah Colter we are ready let's throw
those grades in and we will break down
Isaiah Colter going to the Houston
Texans
[Music]
[Applause]
deshaun Watson gets another weapon a
small scholar Isaiah Coulter from Rhode
Island one of the faster receivers in
this class with the ball in his hands
they ran a for four or five of the
combine my man plays much faster than
that but he's six to 198 pounds this is
not a small receiver kind of Rogers
somebody who can actually play outside
in that X in that Z position I'm big on
Isaiah colder item at 127 overall with
an early round four grade they gave him
here at the end of round five it's a
very very good pick for Bill O'Brien
yeah good height good speed obviously
the testing numbers are where you want
them to be a very straight line runner
but he can also go up and get the
football when you look at culture here
this feels like the insurance for the
inevitable will fuller injury we get all
the time Matt so I looked at Colter I
had an early 6th round raid on them but
I don't think this is a reach by any
means when you're looking for speedy
rods wide receivers this is when you
have to take them in the draft this is a
b-minus for me an area that texans
probably wanted to get some security
because of their injuries yeah I gave it
an A+ I really really do like what he
brings from a speed perspective but also
size again not just a gadgety a small
receiver and I think this is gonna be a
need for Houston even with some of the
players they've added that like a
Brandon cooks like a Randall Cobb I
compared him to Randall Cobb is that
type of impact inside player so I think
we'll see Isaiah Colter get into this
Houston Texans offense early on in his
career all right so the Texans get
another receiver Isaiah Colter going
there and then at 172 Connor we have the
Detroit Lions will be on the clock 173
the Eagles so starting to fly a little
bit as we get toward the end of round 5
so any little lie or get some momentum
on wide receivers here Matt speed wide
receivers so you know no DPJ Isaiah
Hodgins KJ Hill those guys are kind of a
like great great hands reliable in that
regard they're just not gonna win down
the field a lot so if you're looking to
wonder who the next speed ride receiver
is off the board would be I got Darnell
Mooney and Tristan Jack
and as the next guys in that category
Matt who are you looking at that can win
down the field yeah you know there's
Donovan people's Jones would be the one
where you're like gosh why is this guy
still available so we actually have the
pic here just came in the Houston Texans
take a running back
Jason Huntley at running back a little
bit of a surprise I'm gonna be honest I
don't know if he made our final board as
we cut it to 400 players we'll see I
should be the Detroit rare play I pull
it I do yeah so I apologize that is the
Detroit Lions take it running back
Jason Huntley from New Mexico State the
Aggies get a running back in the draft
and I'm checking nope we cut him so he
was at player like 470 overall so that's
gonna be a reach yeah and I'm a little
confused why you know Benjamin has not
come off the board yet and to give you
some notes on Jason Huntley it's a speed
pick okay there you know there's reports
that he's a 4-3 kind of runner he's very
tall he's five foot eight you know
probably gonna play about 185 so to give
you guys some information on him
teams are there's a trend right now in
the fifth round going on with players
that were graded in sixth round range to
UDF a status teams are reaching on speed
which that's okay I'll about it yep it's
absolutely perfectly said it's just the
hey let's take speed players and one
thing to note this year teams are very
worried about undrafted free agents
about the communication to be able to
lock those up so normally a player like
this would be an undrafted free agent
you have an area scout call him later
today and lock up that priority free
agent contract they're very worried
about that this year so I think we're
gonna see more players like a Jason
Huntley who you want to make sure you
get we're gonna see those guys drafted
instead of go undrafted and just locked
up with a signing bonus and Matt I want
to jump in here and say one thing I saw
this on Twitter it's from Zach Cruz
there have been twenty five wide
receivers taken in this draft guess how
many of the Green Bay Packers have taken
none I just don't get it I don't get it
yeah I'm not you hate Aaron Rodgers like
I like Allen Lazard and Davante Adams
but can you get the kidney this is a
great
wide receiver class read the room I mean
it is great we're gonna take three yeah
go ahead right yeah even the Titan they
took basically a fullback I did see a
quote this morning the Matt Lafleur was
like we're gonna run the ball we're
gonna we're gonna establish the run I
don't know if he understands what year
it is that no one's doing that anymore
they even Tennessee they had to start
throwing the ball to win with Ryan
Tannehill so even if you have a good
running back no one establishes the run
anymore and I just thought I don't know
it feels very out of touch with where
the league is going especially I'm not
the biggest Aaron Rodgers fan of the
road but Aaron Rodgers a Hall of Famer
he's one of the best quarterbacks in the
NFL and you're not you're not helping
him you're not drafting wide receivers
it's it's definitely shocking and I
think if you had told Packers fans a
couple days ago you're gonna be at the
end around five and I have a wide
receiver they would have they wouldn't
have believed you they would have come
at you and told you that you had no idea
what you're talking about
yeah and I mean I'm job would probably
tell myself that if someone told me that
so I don't understand I'm just not
really sure what's happening right now
yeah we have a trade the Bears are on
the clock the Eagles traded out the
Bears trade up Connor you said we're
seeing a run on speed here's another one
Darnell Mooney a wide receiver from 219
is the pickup 173 so more speed being
drafted here late in the fifth round
Mooney was a late riser for me and
talking to folks at one point it was
like where does he play not breaking
this one down with a grade so go and put
it here for three eight speed so oh
goodness
510 176 he's a little light in all caps
of my notes I wrote bad hands so that's
a concern this is a jet sweep option
this is a special teams player but late
round five I'm okay roll the dice on
four three eight yeah Matt he's the poor
man's version of KJ handler in this
draft is what he is two guys that have
significant problems catching the ball
incredible speed very small bodies will
play special teams you know not as
electric as hammer you know strength
concerns but somebody that once again
can absolutely fly a look at it here I
had a sixth-round grade on them the
speeds always gonna bump them up at
least around so this is I'm okay with
this pick yeah again yeah you want speed
you trade up to get it so
you understand that we're gonna get a
look at our best players available here
in just uh right now look at that
Donovan people's Jones Stanford Samuels
Bradley and I AJ Green now a hunter
Bryant is the reason I was hoping we
would get to see this I don't know what
happened here we got hunter Brian on the
podcast thought he did a good job he's a
good athlete I know he didn't test as
well as he had a hope to but Hunter
Bryant was on my board at 110 overall
and you could look at it say Oh a 6-2 is
250 where do you play him I think he's
better than Josiah to gora who the
Packers took earlier in this draft oh
it's not even close I think when you
watch Hunter Bryant's film it's very
obvious he gained too much muscle for
the combine and just ran a worse time
than all of us expected he should not
have put on that weight he needs to
accept that he is a move tight end at
the next level and I like that he's a
tough player he wanted to show people
hey I can block I think when we spoke to
him at pretty sure he said he was
watching a lot of Delanie Walker and
Evan Engram so yes I respect that
attitude from Hunter Bryant but I think
he's at his best when he's playing like
a big wide receiver instead of a true
tight end I think he's faster than the
numbers say I thought the film was very
very good he has no business being on
the board and I'll tell you right now
I'll put my money on it if he goes to a
good landing spot that can feature him
as a tight end to he'll be the steal of
the fifth or sixth round yeah we see it
every year tight ends fall they go to
the right scheme they end up being very
very good players because you just get
that right fit so I'm surprised that
hunter Bryant is still on the board
alright I pick 170 for the Tennessee
Titans go with the defensive lineman
from NC State Liril Murchison Tennessee
Titans we know Mike variables trying to
build that defense up they took Jeffrey
Simmons in the first round last year
they're rumored to be adding Jadeveon
Clowney and free agency has an edge
rusher but they lost your OKC
so Larry Murchison we're gonna break
this one down great that were able I
wish I had a vest on full Mike Vrabel
maybe next year maybe next year we'll uh
we'll come in costume for day three you
can dress is your favorite NFL coach
yeah but let's give this fun I could go
the mustache in the vest and try to grow
five inches and gained 45 pounds of
muscle all right we're gonna break down
Larimore to send the defensive lineman
from NC State
lieutenancy titans trade drill Casey
they may have just drafted his
replacement larold Murchison and
interior defensive lineman from the NC
State Wolfpack six to three hundred
pounds he ran a 505 in the 40-yard dash
Connor
J Rogers our guy is a nose tackle
through and through late fifth round is
where I had him graded 189 overall what
do you think about Murchison going to
the Tennessee Titans I had him in the
same exact range Matt I like this pick
from Mike Vrabel merchants ins a tough
guy he's probably undersized to be
playing the 0 or the 1 Tech but he moves
very well and he is relentless you're
gonna see it here he's a guy that loves
to get downfield and make plays so when
I watch Murchison listen small school
guy but he's kind of the later round of
somebody like Justin Matt a bouquet
somebody that can shoot gaps really
great with his hands rarely rarely ever
gets thrown around which I respect that
I love this guitar celebration that's
one of my favorite things about him in
this draft so when we look at this one
I'm gonna give this one a name - at this
point of the draft actually I watched
him play I think he's the best interior
defensive lineman available when you
went going back to watching him play he
seemed screams Mike Vrabel guy a tough
guy
hot motor all the time I don't care that
he went to a small school he can hang
with the big dogs ya know I love it as
well I'm gonna give this a be where it's
at the value is good this is where I
would draft more nose tackles just kid
space eaters the middle of the defensive
line here Tennessee Titans get Lera
Merson from North Carolina State
[Music]
hey Connor there Green Bay Packers it
absolutely is the Green Bay Packers were
on the clock you talked about 25 wide
receivers they haven't drafted one
Donovan peoples Jones is on the board
nope they take Kamal Martin a linebacker
for Minnesota oh so okay good I know
what they're doing
yeah but he can't catch the ball I don't
think I do not believe following him to
wide receiver and I know they had
awesome guys in free agency at
linebacker but once again and with Kemal
Martin or Fred Jim naggy executive
director senior bola told me had he not
had to drop because injury they thought
he was really gonna blow up there that
he was gonna show up he's a good athlete
unfortunately missed five games with
injury this past year come on Martin was
a very good player you know we talked a
lot about Antoine Winfield jr. you would
see Kamal Martin in those clips a lot
him making plays he stood out any time
you watched film of minutes the
Minnesota Gophers I like Kamal Martin
here I did drop him because injury
wasn't sure he would get drafted but he
goes here late fifth round to the Green
Bay Packers yeah guy that can make plays
you can fly around in the front seven I
think you have to like that I love that
you brought up you know when you watch
Antoine Winfield junior another player
that was asked to play up front a lot
those are the two making all the plays
in the backfield so it's not that it's a
bad player or a bad pick in regards I
just think we're sitting here kind of
wondering the Packers strategy right
like we like Jordan love but the
strategy of tape right Jordan love and
even when you look at you know taking a
blocking tight end fullback it's okay
cuz you're a good running team but at
some point you do need to improve on the
areas where they've been
it's almost like an outcry for help at
this point it does make you wonder how
long Aaron Rodgers is going to put up
with this he's not always how speak his
mind yeah there you go yeah absolutely
four more picks in around five than
Connor and I get a much needed we think
well-deserved break
you can see Chiefs will be up shortly a
Sunday headline from Tristan Morgan in
the app says Aaron Rodgers says kiss my
you-know-what Green Bay I want out
all right
176 the Minnesota Vikings draft KJ
Osbourne a wide receiver out of Miami so
again this run on speed is happening it
is real the Minnesota Vikings wanted to
get involved after taking Justin
Jefferson in the first round Connor KJ
Osborne was on the fringe of draftable
for me 304 overall but he ran a 4 for 8
at 511 206 pounds the production was
never quite there at the you where you
wanted it to be yeah and I think listen
they had their problems at quarterback
over the years right but I'm with you
that the you know the hype was never
really there I think we didn't expect
him to be drafted when we were doing the
stream so I think that's kind of my
question with this I I just like players
on but like I don't really understand
not valuing somebody like Isaiah Hodgins
in this spot and it's not I don't think
I was born is this great speedster where
that's the difference here so I mean
once again they're not gonna sit here
and just take a dump on all these picks
like this it's you know this is
splitting hairs at this point but it
would not be a receiver in my top 200
Matt I'll say that right yeah as far as
grade I gave him a grade of 50 which was
our cutoff point of are you NFL caliber
so he was pretty far down the board and
he was wide receiver number 49 so we've
seen a lot of receivers drafted we're
not quite that deep into the talent pool
where you want number 49 coming off the
board
alright the a thank you to the over
9,000 people as we get towards the end
of the fifth round watching with us that
are truly truly special
we'd love having you guys here we're
trying to do something different than TV
and hopefully you join us for many years
to come as we do this for at least
rounds one through five yeah it's been a
good time it's great to talk about these
players that we've evaluated researched
investigated I mean you don't feel deep
dive on these players and it's cool to
see them come off the board here three
picks left Connor in this round which is
today is flown by can't believe I'm
sitting here it's 2:30 Central Time
three picks left the Kansas City Chiefs
at 177 Denver Broncos at 178 the Dallas
Cowboys at 179 so we're getting to the
end of this round still good players on
the board the Chiefs have been
I would say aggressive in this draft
Clyde Edwards a layer in the first round
Willie gay jr. in the second round going
off in supply and Lucas nying in the
third
they've been aggressive about going
toward the offense we thought they had
Bryce Hall they get luxurious needs so
they get a speedster in the secondary in
round four round five they have not
traded Chris Jones they have not
addressed the defensive tackle position
so could we see anterior offensive line
I know a number two tight end is
something that they've been rumored to
want to address they're pretty good at
quarterback I think they're okay there
but yeah Riley any direction yeah what
do you think of Darryl Williams in this
spot Matt yeah I would like that I think
he fits that if he especially as a
sinner coming out in Mississippi State
he moves well enough I think he plays
mean enough he plays nasty enough I
would double-dip probably at the corner
position and go after someone like I
like Dane Jackson from pit like Lamar
Jackson Nebraska Jabbar boss still not
taken right another slot corner I would
be intrigued by Hunter Bryant or
Thaddeus Moss just to have that number
to tide in who can play more of an
h-back role but they do have Anthony
Sherman a fullback who's very very good
at what he does so there are a lot of
options on the board for them we have a
comment here that says and it's FA seven
head Chiefs gonna get KJ Hill for a
steal here if taking a wide receiver I
think we would all be like come on guys
you don't need another receiver but
you're showing up DeMarcus Robinson will
be up yeah I mean how many you have to
have a certain number of linemen you you
can't just can't just throw all right
here's the remaining players on the big
board you get that overall to the left
Donovan people's Jones Stanford Samuels
with like him for Kansas City Bradley an
eye AJ Green Hunter Bryant just
mentioned Isaiah Hodgins I actually
think he has two strongest hands of
anyone in this trap Prince tiga wanna go
Bryce Huff Thaddeus Moss and Jared paint
me a couple tight ends the pic is in
though Connor at 177 overall yes you can
city chiefs elect Michael Dana the edge
rusher from Michigan so big program we
saw Josh you che go much earlier in the
draft they get Michael Dana six two
children
see one pounds they lost a couple guys
in for agency that were rotational
players obviously D Ford was trained to
last year now you get some depth at
least for that defensive end position
yeah and a little bit of a different
player than Josh okay I would say here
Matt I think he's got a little bit more
size and strengthen a little bit you
know that squaty kind of frame the
production was not as impressive as okay
of course but definitely a different
kind of edge setting player yeah no
you're right and I think the way
Michigan used him I wonder if you even
try to have him stand up a linebacker a
little bit and then okay you can rush
the quarterback someone third down but
where the Chiefs have needs mention it
Alex Okafor starter defensive end
Breeland speaks I don't if we're ever
gonna get see much production out of him
tato passing yon who did have some good
moments last year they need something
opposite Frank Clark you're hoping late
bit around you can get something here
the Denver Broncos with the
second-to-last pick in this round have
drafted Justin's ster nod from Wake
Forest at linebacker so the Broncos this
was a big need for them coming into the
strap they've mostly just gone higher
since they get a linebacker here yep is
a good player was a top 150 pick I
believe on my board 158 it was close
with that but a very very good athlete a
linebacker let's get our grades ready
and we will break this video down the
Denver Broncos needed an athlete in the
middle of the field and they get one
with Justin's turnout from Wake Forest
the linebacker who a fortunate or biceps
injury affected his draft stock but a
474 40-yard dash at 6-3 240 pounds
Connor late late round five I hear
getting a linebacker who could at least
come in and play some early reps in his
rookie season
I think so Matt I like this guy's range
I think he has really really good
closing speed a good tackler when you
watch turn that play I think it's
somebody that would have went a lot
higher if you didn't have that ruptured
bicep injury halfway through his season
and there you go
closing speed I mean spy and then attack
and they'll sit him in the middle of the
field and he'll read his keys and he'll
make plays he's gonna be a good Blitzer
he's somebody once again the range is
there to go sideline to sideline so this
the draft he was one of my top off ball
linebackers available
I like this pick for the Broncos out of
need it's a B+ for me with Stern ad
going Denver I wouldn't be - I like the
value I like the athlete our comp in the
draft 400 scouting reports you should be
checking out with Fred Warner so a lot
of upside with justice or not from Wake
Forest going to the Denver Broncos all
right and the Dallas Cowboys are up with
the last pick in this round
guess who they took down with people's
Jones nope no I'm just the other wall oh
okay it looks like it's Bradley and I
all right
have a look another part maybe they need
to leave Jerry alone more often the man
knows what he's doing he read the mock
drafts this year he did yeah just being
patient get your grade ready Connor
we're definitely gonna talk about
Bradley and I because we've been talking
about him since round three it feels
like the guy's got a much much needed
edge rusher here the Dallas Cowboys get
what might be the steal of the draft
Bradley an IED defensive and outside
linebacker from the Utah Utes he's a
power rusher 6-3 257 pounds falls in the
draft because people are concerned we're
in a 493 40 at the Scouting Combine
don't care I don't ever want to watch
him run 40 yards again it's that first
step quickness the power in his hands
that had me great him as a late round 2
player with a comparison to Whitney
merciless I'm a big fan of Bradley and I
the power in his game is exceptional
he's in it felt ready as the last pick
in the 5th round I'm a huge fan I mean
we saw CD lamb a top-five player fall of
them at 17 we see Bradley and I a third
round player folded them all the way in
the 5th round here today Matt let's talk
about the player great first step really
good hands a technician and he found his
pass rush plan this year to get
double-digit sacks we saw him working a
counter move we saw him go cross face we
saw him use a spin move
I love Bradley and I he's not a guy who
put in as a three down defender to stop
the run he's a guy you put on past
Downs third down you set him off the
edge and you let him go so they lost
Robert Quinn in free agency
the Bears paid him way way too much
money that the Cowboys were not gonna
match you get a great value in Bradley
and I in the fifth round here
it's an a-plus for me Dallas Cowboys are
rocking and rolling right now absolutely
same here a plus for the Dallas Cowboys
Jerry Jones you were having yourself a
heck of a draft go and buy another yacht
let me borrow yours Bradley and I go
into the Dallas Cowboys with the last
pick and the 5th round in 2020 NFL Draft
alright round five is over
Connor Rose thank you so much thank you
to the audience leaving your comments
hanging with us having fun doing it the
bleacher report way we absolutely
appreciate everyone in the app hanging
out leaving those comments everyone
watching on YouTube we definitely
appreciate it thank you guys for
allowing us to do our dream jobs miked
interior bleach reporter believe this is
your fifth draft of bleacher report
thank you
we know that we couldn't do this show we
couldn't do our stick to football
podcast without you guys
contributing watching commenting having
fun telling your friends so thank you
thank you so much there's a ton more
content coming all weekend in the
Bleacher Report app keep using it get
your friends to use it
check out the group chat and check out
us stick to football Monday Wednesday
Thursday for more breakdowns of the 2020
NFL draft class Bradham left go for our
amazing production team for the amazing
content team the social media crew
everybody running the lights the cameras
we had setups in Joplin Missouri
we had setups in Hoboken New Jersey we
have setup somewhere in Manhattan Adam
left Co lives and it went off flawlessly
thank you all so much for making the
2020 NFL Draft happen we appreciate you
all don't forget to check us out we'll
be back right here in this app cover
more the 2020 draft
[Music]
[Music]